of our country I mean it's quite
astonishing but it is an exit poll let's
see how it is an exit poll and it could
be the case we expect it won't be the
tab live Valley is an outlier listen now
you're watching the brexit election on
Sky News it's just gone midnight let me
take you through these dramatic
headlines so far the first results are
in and the Conservatives have gained a
seat as we've just been mentioning in
the northeast its Blythe Valley but
labour held on in Newcastle Central and
happened and Sunderland South we were
hoping to hear from one of the returned
candidates there but let me tell you
Labour's vote chair has dropped more
than 18 percent in Sunderland and
Houghton John Bercow our special guest
here tonight telling us said the early
results are a catastrophe for labour and
the exit poll for Sky News the BBC and
ITV News has predicted that the
Conservative Party and this is why we're
predicting it could be a catastrophe for
the Labour Party that the Conservatives
will get 368 seats on that exit poll
that would be a majority of 86 it is
suggesting that for labour they dip
below 200 seats secure 191 seats or so
now that would be their lowest number of
seats for many decades since 1935 in
actual fact the Shadow Chancellor John
MacDonald told us the situation does
look dramatically bad ad after the exit
poll Boris Johnson thanked voters on
Twitter saying we live in the greatest
democracy in the world that for the
Prime Minister
[Music]
well John Bercow you've made our
headlines imagine that years sitting
right beside us but I mean the serious
point being if we've got to keep saying
that but the early results confirming
that trend there and what I was saying
to bethe before we hit 12 o'clock
they're buried God that John McDonald
have all been on the program and they're
there looking pretty shell-shocked yes
they're obviously very deflated to put
it mildly
everybody insert some quite rightly the
caveat let's wait to see whether these
early extrapolations are replicated
elsewhere in the country but if on any
significant scale we see what we've seen
over the last hour elsewhere in the
north and in the midlands that spells
doom for labor I should say in relation
to Bridget philipson I mean she's a very
dedicated name Huntress and principal
Member of Parliament Helton and some
land south and very active in the House
of Commons but she's on fire while
you're on Sunderland in your
unsurpassable knowledge of these seeds
we've got Sunderland Central I'm hearing
they will count in this in the same
building they're they're due to declare
now this really--it yeah and this but
this could be better for the
Conservatives yes it's perfectly
possible that it could be Julie Elliot
is the outgoing and long-standing member
Republic but the exit well the exit poll
is suggesting because he does do seed by
seed and I was suggesting that it's too
close to call in Sunderland central well
again you've got the brexit fact I come
back to this point that we touched on
earlier Dermot that in Newcastle of
course they voted to remain in the
European Union in Sunderland back in
2016 there was that sharp intake of
breath when the results from Sunderland
were announced was a very heavy leave
vote and I have to assume that there is
a link between that heavy leave Oh on
the one hand and the punishment of
labour members of parliament and
candidates on the other yeah much reduce
what we'll have to see what happens
exactly that we sharp intake of breath
if the Conservatives take Sunderland
central roads you know Sarah Jamie is in
Sunderland forests and can update a
Sarah Jane
hey Rupp yeah hide Irma and we've just
been given a three-minute warning here
the returning officer has asked for all
these Sunderland central candidates to
gather to the right of the stage they're
all in a huddle at the moment they're
then take to the stage behind me in the
returning officer Patrick Melia will
announce that result it's really
interesting actually el labor sorry so
Jake Newcastle East is declaring let's
see how it goes one tiny East
constituency is as follows
Nikolas Hugh Brown Labour Party 26,000
and forty nine votes
Robert Charles Patrick wind also known
as Robin win the Conservative Party ten
thousand five hundred and eighty six
votes Nikolas Terry hartley also known
as Nick Hartley Green Party candidate
[Music]
2195 Wendy Barbara okay we leave there
Nick Brown long standing Labour MP there
are back in vote down ever so slightly
we were concentrating on something
central wearing it's too close to call
Sarah Jenna me is there I think we're
getting a declaration acting returning
officer hereby give notice that the
total number of votes for each candidate
for the Sun Dance Central constituency
is as follows Tom the silver the
Conservative Party fifteen thousand
three hundred and seventy two
Julie Elliot Labour Party 18,000
Rachel
okay
Thank You Rachel Sarah Featherston green
party
[Music]
1212 Niall Jane Hudson Liberal Democrat
3025 Dale Mackenzie independent 484
[Music]
corral cash Akuma Parikh 5000 and 47
and that Julie Elliot has been duly
elected to serve as member for the said
constituency today very few sub Julie
Elliot is back there as the Labour MP
for silent central with a much reduced
majorities you know we're talking to
Sarah Jamie who's who's right there and
well back but shaved that majority way
down the Conservatives and indeed the
brexit party Sarah Jane yes indeed I'm
Julie Elliot's the majority last time
out was nine thousand nine hundred
ninety seven reduced significantly to
two thousand nine hundred and sixty four
here tonight a lot of folks actually
went the Lib Dems way the last Lib Dem
candidate got one thousand seven hundred
and seventy seven votes that has got up
to three thousand this time round which
is interesting but Julie Elliott hangs
on to Sunderland central there had been
a rumor that that tonight could turn
blue but it remains red the ceiling
she's just making her acceptance speech
we're still awaiting the Washington and
Sunderland West result but we'll bring
that to you as soon as we get it Dermot
okay yeah Jane thank you very much
indeed let's stay on that change in
share in Sunderland Central though we
were told it's too close to call well it
wasn't but it was by the standards of
the the previous majority held there by
Julie La Tercera Jane was saying it was
nearly almost exactly ten thousand after
the last election nine thousand nine
hundred ninety seven well wax down by
thirteen point four percent and you can
see there the performance of the brexit
party just to remind you the brexit
party did not stand in this general
election against conservative candidates
where the seat had been held by the
Conservatives but did in the main stand
against the Labour Party and perhaps
that explains the effect the
conservative vote more or less unchanged
they're two percent Lib Dems actually up
quite a lot they're doubled their vote
in the greens at one point two percent
John burka we keep relating this to the
exit poll and it's pretty much in line
if you put those vote chairs the change
in shares on labor seats with smaller
majorities then they're going to be
getting home in a lot of seats where we
previously thought they did another
squeak yes I mean this is
another very bad result and anything
it's a personal reflection on Julianne
[ __ ] she's extremely active in the
house I've heard her speak on fire
stations and court services and
transport infrastructure and state
pension inequality for women of a
certain age and so on and so forth she's
a very dedicated in deciduous member but
we come back to this point is the Labour
Party not able to resonate with the
voters in an area that voted heavily and
even the answer is clearly it isn't
resonating and in a sense you could
argue that only the intervention of the
brexit party calls that Pro brexit vote
to split a bit and it probably already
saved Julie's bacon and what about
Bridget Phillips in next-door because
you mentioned they leave remain votes
Bridget philipson I mean as you who saw
up close and personal in the House of
Commons was quite an avid remainer in
her in a very leave leaning seat yes she
was and he is an avid remainer
and she has also been an outspoken
advocate of a second referendum and I
mentioned this not in any sense to
indict her or to be pejorative but
simply to say that she made a calculated
decision that she would get that
proposition out there and I suspect it
hasn't helped her locally it's what she
believes is the right way forward in
relation to the brexit but I suspect
that it got a very poor response in her
a let's get Beth's thoughts on this and
we're looking at seats here which we
imagined because as a whole deluge of
seats to to declare over the next three
or four hours these Southie these are
the early declares which traditionally
it's just mean about who's first to
declare they're telling us that they're
not sorry and pretty on the numbers and
it's gonna be dire for the way but one
of my labour sources has said to me that
this looks in terms of the early results
that the exit poll is looking pretty
accurate actually in terms of
extrapolating out the exit poll from the
early results I mean it's interested in
this particularly in Sunderland central
the brexit party vote if you add it to
the conservative vote would have given
them a majority what I think would be
really interesting about this though
when we begin to chew over this in the
coming days is to the extent to which
the vote was lent to the Conservatives
Jesus Stuart
vote leave labour MP now not an MP
anymore did a big press conference with
Boris Johnson and Michael gave where she
said please if you're a Labour voter
lend Boris Johnson your vote lend your
vote was the phrase in order to get
brexit done and that appears to have
resonated and the question is and let's
talk about the conservative sentence and
that is the issue isn't it John Bercow
if this is kind of a referendum through
the prism of a general election there's
been a single answer single slogan
certainly more or less from the
Conservatives about getting brexit done
well then with that kind of majority
you're in for five years and you've got
to satisfy then those people who have as
best as lent you your vote yes there's a
huge public policy challenge first in
the delivery of brexit because once the
government is back in office and
ministers are as Roy Jenkins used to say
in central command of affairs they've
got to deliver they've got to make it
happen they've got to show that what
they've promised can be translated into
practice and that's on brexit where you
are dealing with a lot of other players
on the stage my point earlier to Beth
was yeah legislatively of course the
government can give effect to the
withdrawal agreement because it's got
the numbers but there are other people
with whom we have to interact and
negotiate and then secondly the question
is having had those votes linked to it
can the Conservative Party craft a wider
policy prospectus that will appeal to
those voters whose votes have been given
to them tonight well again talking about
it this evening but as those brexit
negotiations continue you're very aware
you've heard it many many times in the
chamber of the House of Commons the
argument coming and let's give a name to
it from people like Jacob Riis mark
who's saying what we can do zero tariffs
you know we can go to World Trade
Organization rules and we'll well put no
tariffs on agricultural goods and things
like that
everything will be cheaper for the
British public but of course an awful
lot of people in various industries
would be put out of work there'd be a
complete rebalancing of the British
economy do you think people who voted
for the Conservative Party voted for for
that brand of conservatism no I don't
think people who voted for the
the party tonight voted on the basis of
a closely argued interpretation of
tariff or non-tariff barrier policy and
I don't say that to be discourteous or
insulting I think people are making an
overall judgement about what motivates
them on what they would like to happen
but the idea that people have voted in
very large numbers for a particular form
of brexit I think really would be
stretching a point okay I think what
they've done is vote to say we are
frustrated we want to see progress we
haven't had it let's get it but as to
the results no no no I'm John plenty
more to discuss on that issue as these
results come in and put more flesh on
the bones of that exit poll plenty more
from our correspondents at election
counts tonight we've got so many covered
and there are some crucial votes taking
place in Yorkshire and as you've seen in
the northeast of England
they've got leads Wakefield and
Hartlepool covered early well let's go
to Sally Lockwood in Leeds first we
haven't visited you yet and what's the
mood there Sally well it's very busy
here Dermer Leeds arena there are eight
constituencies being counted here at the
moment behind me five of those labour
seats and three of those marginals to
help ID Conservatives which were
challenged by labour tonight and another
which was a Lib Dem target seat as well
well out of those three marginal seats
done it really does seem that only leads
Northwest could be vulnerable but that's
of course only according to that exit
poll what more will be clear after 2:30
as those results come in but one to
watch is is putzie which has a majority
of only 331 votes for conservative
Stuart Andrew there he lost four
thousand of his majority to labour in
the last election but according to the
exit poll he'll hold that tonight so
we'll see we are going to get those
votes from 230 running to about five
o'clock we've been told we will have to
clear out if the counting goes on beyond
that because they need to set up
for a Vengaboys concert for tomorrow
night
John Bercow saying what who are they
a popular beat combo m'lud okay let's
talk to Nick fowl in Wakefield now well
even before the voting took place we
think it could be well a narrow squeak
or maybe a heavy defeat there are four
Mary crow yeah I think she is probably
facing a defeat them no beat combos here
John burger be delighted to know but a
Labour source has told me already who's
involved we want the other two seats
here that he thinks Wakefield has gone
that Mary crazed insistence on beating
the romaine drum is going to cost her in
an area here which is very heavily leave
at the referendum and if you assume that
that is correct that leaves two other
red bricks from that wall are they under
pressure as well if vet Cooper not part
of the inner Jeremy Corbyn sanctum got
twice as many votes almost exactly as
the conservative last time the feeling
on the labor side is that she may be
okay and John Trickett in the Hemsworth
constituency who is in the Shadow
Cabinet he - not certainly survived such
is the scale of the labor collapse in
this part of the country and indeed
around the country German my goodness me
okay Nick plenty more - a check in with
you when the time comes
let's go to Gerard tub though in
Hartlepool and Jared very interesting
they're given what we've seen happening
already in parts of the Northeast yes a
good performance by the Conservative
Party but the brexit party doing well
and their chairman standing there
in a constituency that's had a Labour MP
for 55 years richard theis of course
could pick wherever he wanted to go he
and Nigel Farage have put this party
that Nigel Farage said is a company not
a political party together so richard
theis chose this seat because he thought
about 7650 majority that Mike Hill the
Labour MP had was vulnerable 70% voted
to leave here but boy this is this
doesn't feel like a conservative seat
high unemployment high benefit rates
more chance of dying on average young if
you live here lower education attainment
on average etc not that many
professionals they haven't voted if
they've voted
conservative here for a small state for
individualism for for freedom of of
trade they voted because seven out of
ten who voted at the referendum wanted
out of Europe the question is can
Richard Tice capitalize on that
frustration have they voted for him
looking at the votes tallied up on the
table now Mike Hill looks to have more
of course you don't know because you
don't know which wards have been stacked
up there but there's plenty on Richard
Tice's table plenty on the Conservatives
as well it's gonna be quite tight Gerard
thank you very much indeed goes without
saying back with you later of course
cinder thanks to Nick and Sally as well
that we're live in many more cants like
those as well we're watching Sheffield
or one of these significant developments
there the Lib Dems have hopes of
regaining sheffield hallam er the seat
held by Nick Clegg which he lost in 2017
also watching Doncaster there are three
Labour held seats while they were labour
held at least one of which a major poll
suggested was at risk of falling to the
Conservatives that's also true of
Grimsby Labour's majorities just 2,500
any day you could see litter that was
one of the seats Boris Johnson
campaigned in towards the close of the
campaign well listen let's talk to the
brexit secretary now not the brexit
secretary it's michael gut yes Barry
here's Michael Gove very good to see you
tell me this do you believe the exit
poll are you heartened by it well I
think it's still too soon when we've
only had a limited number of results
declared to be confident that the exit
poll is right in all its particulars but
I do think it points to the fact that
Jeremy Corbyn appears to have been
decisively rejected by labour voters and
I think that there are three things that
we can draw so far from what we've seen
the first is that jeremy corbyn's
approached a brexit his failure to
ensure that he honored his manifesto
commitment in 2017 to get brexit dom
that's clearly labour I think it's also
the case that the more that voters saw
Jeremy Corbyn and his approach both on
national security and on economics the
more they felt that he was not the right
person to be Prime Minister I think the
the third lesson that we we we should
draw from this is that related to the
first people wanted a democratic vote to
be respected they've looked at
Parliament over the course of the last
three and a half years they've seen that
a variety of MPs have been you know
trying to frustrate that verdict and
they wanted to make sure that they had a
strong prime minister who would deliver
that that appears ke the verdict okay
and it's appears to have resonated let's
talk Mr Gove about the the seats we have
seen declare I mean did you expect
you're out the campaign trail of course
did you expect to do so well in those
parts of the the northeast these are in
the main labour Reid dance
I certainly the case that we have some
very good candidates in the Northeast
and in Levy who won in implied a mental
health worker in the NHS is someone who
I know will be a superb MP but I'll be
honest I didn't expect that we would
necessarily win that seat I'm delighted
through the key in her as I knew he
fought a brilliant campaign but I mean
there is the fact looking at it as well
the brexit party also doing well and
Boris Johnson said
didn't he he said well you know if you
vote for the brexit party you'll be
taking votes away from us and you may
let Jeremy Corbyn it seems that may not
be the case almost certainly won't be
the case according to the exit poll but
nevertheless you might have done even
better perhaps in some of those seats
that have already declared if the brexit
party weren't there I think that is
probably true again I want to be
cautious at this stage perhaps more
cautious than you'd like to omit so my
apologies but we still to see if what
the pattern is across the country but it
was certainly the case that we argued
during the election I think it's true
that a vote for other parties other than
the Conservatives risked us not getting
a majority people understood how
important it was I hope that we didn't
heat the mistakes for the person to have
a hung parliament well let's get back to
the central promise you say that it
seems to have hung on lot this general
election that is of course getting
brexit done do you really believe that
brexit can be done in the form of the
withdrawal agreement well yes that's
that's almost certainly going to pass if
it is a majority of that size but do you
really think that brexit all of it can
be done and dusted by the end of the
year yes not this year by the end of
next year that a trade agreement that a
trade agreements as Michel Barnier says
not really any chance whatsoever a
comprehensive trade agreement can be
renegotiated with the European Union in
11 months
well Michel is a tough negotiator he
would say that at this stage and the
negotiations but if we look at the past
it was the case that when Boris Johnson
was renegotiating their withdrawal
agreement people said you can't change a
word of it and he said well in
particular I want to get rid of the
backstop and they tell you you can't do
that that's inviolable but the Prime
Minister succeeded in changing the
withdrawal agreement which nobody said
could be done and getting rid of the
backstop which again very very few
people acknowledged was likely to happen
so of course I think it's important for
us to recognize there's a lot of work to
be done but we can do it and we must do
it as quickly as possible and if it
can't be done you know if it finds you
run into some difficulties isn't it
prudent to have an extension to the
transition period in place as tourism a
negotiated or you saying we will never
use that under any
Constance's a long time ago I was a
reporter deadlines concentrate minds and
it's really important that we get this
withdrawal agreement through the House
of Commons by January the 31st and we
can then get on with making sure that
the other policies which were in our
manifesto which the public would expect
us to deliver on additional investment
in the NHS in fighting crime and in
leveling up educational opportunity are
delivered as well but you'll be aware
obviously um that deadlines have been
missed by this very prime minister who
was going to die in a ditch if we didn't
leave by the end of October you know on
a pragmatic basis see for necessary
reasons and it seems being vindicated in
the strategy if this is going to be the
election outcome but nevertheless if
circumstances dictates you don't know
what's out there an extension might be
useful well I think that everyone knows
and certainly if this exit poll is
correct the majority of the public
appreciated that the fact that the
October 31st deadline set was through no
fault of the prime ministers it was
because there were individuals in
Parliament you know they've perfectly
respectable arguments they made but they
ran counter to what what now appears to
be the strong public desire to have
secured our exit in a timely way but I
mean have they voted for that date at
the end of 2020 or have they not just
voted people not just voted for January
the 31st
get that withdrawal agreement through
and then that the legal leaving of the
European Union has taken place yes
Britain has left yes
but that's what I'm saying that's what
they voted for that and voted for the
end bit do they have they voted for what
happens at the end of 2020 according to
your timetable well again being cautious
if it is the case that we have a
majority then people who voted for the
Prime Minister Boris Johnson it's it's
his victory and the Prime Minister was
very clear that he would use a mandate
if the British people gave him one to
make sure that we had the withdrawal
agreement concluded by the 31st and we
then moved quickly and expeditiously to
secure a new arrangement with the EU
based on free trade and friendly
cooperation but we can do that in a
timely way absolutely ok and what about
our No Deal planning I know you're a
sister in the
election campaign you're gonna keep that
going in in case the talks don't go well
and you will stick to leaving at sorry
it's who leaving the transition period
at the end of 2020 well I think that
quite a lot of the planning that was
called no deal planning was planning for
live outside the single market and the
customs union and that work of preparing
Britain for life outside the European
Union will go on but we know now if this
exit poll is correct but the government
should have a majority which will allow
us to conclude a good deal as the
promise was said an oven ready deal
which we can get done by the 31st ok
Marco thank you very much indeed off to
your counter I know thank you very much
indeed maybe talk to you a bit later
well the results are starting to come in
fairly quickly think it's going to speed
up an awful lot more later in the
evening Middlesbrough and there we don't
have the numbers for you a Labour hole
there in Middlesbrough Andy McDonald as
John Bercow is helpfully pointing out
there for labour backing we haven't got
the numbers but it's always interesting
to to see as we've been finding out just
that change in share just have beat the
Conservatives or not they've managed to
penetrate into seats like that we'll get
those numbers for you maybe my colleague
ed Conway has them he's certainly going
to show us what's the results that have
come in so far combined with the exit
poll teller said yeah that's right I
mean let's look at the big picture and
here we have a very big picture indeed
for you have a look at those numbers so
far so you can see those without so far
5 seats for labour one for the Tories
actually bit of a surprise that the
Tories got that boy volley extraordinary
swing and then have a look beyond that
let's fly beyond that scoreboard to see
the map of the UK slowly colouring in
you can see largely curve
north-northeast and seats that are the
first ones typically to declare and we
have those results through but gradually
over the course of the evening and
through into the morning we'll see that
map start to be colored in and we will
see some interesting stories across the
UK especially if that exit poll is right
and it looks rather live from some of
these results like it it will be time to
until we can actually see enough results
to see but listen as we saw newcastle
upon tyne won that race
remember that first race to be the first
constituency to declare and it was new
cost of one south this time around
narrowly beating Houghton and Sunderland
South labour candidates Sheehan whare
and Bridget philipson the first to be
declared back in 2017 and the same again
this time around she were the first this
time and let's have a look to other
constituencies around the UK in
particular I mean when it comes to labor
Durham North West I mean think about
this constituency Laura petcock until
recently I mean still talked about as a
future like cutting you off Swindon
North we alerted you to that it's about
to declare let's have a look here
conservative seat in the last part
obsession is a sports family and
commonly nervous and Bentley 340 1710
[Applause]
[Music]
all Labour Party 16450 just
[Music]
[Applause]
okay well there we have it a
conservative seat before the election
staying a conservative seat with an
increased majority there just in
Tomlinson increasing that majority for
the Conservatives to 16,000 at the last
election it was half out it was 8335 it
is also the constituency that contains
the Honda factory of course having major
concerns about its access to European
markets after her exit but a poor
performance there from the labour party
as well just in Tomlinson has say
doubling that majority let's go through
these numbers for you nearly 60% of the
vote for the Conservatives the Labour on
half at around about 30% the Olympic
Games increasing and there we have it
the Conservatives putting on
five-and-a-half percent the Labour Party
going down eight point six percent the
Lib Dems wear a decent performance up
four point four and the Greens also
increasing their share of the vote now
we mentioned that the result from
Middlesbrough the fact that Labour had
held on there in the form of Andy
McDonald so let's take you through those
numbers were so interested in these
changes in share and in these seats
these labour health seats from the last
Parliament how the brexit parties been
doing well you can see the answer via
cell phone in Middlesbrough not too well
from the brexit party's point of view
but Andy McDonald clearly lost their
deposit there with just over 200 votes
but let's so look at the top line labor
on 17,000 202 and Ruth Betts in for the
Conservatives on 8800 and an independent
there or coming from the council there
with 14 more 2% that's from a standing
start so that's their share of the vote
let's look at the change in share labour
down again 12.2% the Conservatives more
or less level pegging that independent
taking 14 percent the Lib Dems up a
shade as are the greens and the brexit
party now it said just go on a couple of
minutes after midnight you're watching
the brexit election on Sky News better
take you through the headlines so far
the first results are in in the
Conservatives have gained a seat and the
few that have declared in the northeast
Bligh Valley but labour
held Newcastle Central and Houghton and
Sunderland South but with juice
patchouli Elliot's liver partying 18,000
in Sunderland central labour held the
seat but with a reduced majority of just
under 3000 results Justin you've just
seen there in Swindon North
Conservatives have won with an increased
majority and John burka former speaker
has told us the early results are
looking catastrophic for the Labour
Party the exit point for Sky News the
BBC and ITV News has predicted the
Conservative Party will win this general
election and some with 368 seats if that
happens that would equate to a majority
of 86 for Boris Johnson jeremy corbyn's
Labour Party is forecast to win
something around 191 seats now that
would be Labour's worst performance
since before the war since 1935 the
Shadow Chancellor John McDonnell told us
appropriate decisions will be made about
jeremy corbyn's future and after the
exit poll Boris Johnson thanked voters
on Twitter saying live in the greatest
democracy in the world but Michael go
Estela cities it's still too soon for
the Conservatives to be celebrating
well you are watching the brexit
election live here on Sky News what an
extraordinary night it's panning out to
be not an enjoyable one though if the
exit poll is to be believed for the
Labour Party dawn Butler the shadow
equalities minister joins me now very
good evening to You dawn Butler it's
looking pretty bad on that exit poll do
you believe it when I've traveled around
the country and I must admit hadn't felt
that negative so I really do think we
need to see how the rest of the night
pans out but on the results coming in on
the swing you know against labour it it
does seem and feel quite devastating and
did you go to the Northeast because
that's where things really quite did you
go to the Northeast because that's where
the majority of the results have come in
from so far and labour down down down
and down and out in Blyth Valley yeah
unimaginable a couple of elections ago
yeah it is
and brexit obviously played a huge role
there you know ronnie was telling people
to vote conservative to get brixi it
done and you know you cannot deny that
that was a great soundbite you know get
brexit done it's very simple to digest
it's very simple to repeat the fact that
it isn't true and you can't just get
bricks it done didn't really matter so
people I mean and talking about six I
mean we've all were sort of thick of
brexit and but the whole point is it's
not going to be done and it can't be
done simply it only only should being
sick of things they were also sick of
Jeremy Corbyn do you not hear that I
mean a lot a lot of candidates had only
viewed it if a lot of candidates didn't
mention the leader while they were
campaigning to try and get it back in a
lot of labour candidates no mention of
Jeremy Corbyn but it was bought up on
the doorstep was it not oh no I don't
think that's I don't think that's true
hundred percent true um I mean it is
true that there was some things that I
mentioned the doorstep mainly what was
pirated from the media what was out
there print these record low ratings
they weren't made up by the media these
are these are detailed polls no but the
media
tributed to it and that's and that's the
point and also you know if you look at
the fact checking sites that talked
about the advertisements that were
placed by the conservatives eighty-eight
percent of them were false so a lot of
that contributed to it but ultimately
you know we do have to look at these
results we will have to analyze them and
we will have to look at call me
analyzing them I better come in on this
just your colleague Gareth's now he has
just said stoke central he said he says
he thinks he's lost his seat and he said
publicly that he thinks that Jeremy
Corbyn should resign I mean this would
be the worst result in terms of seats
for the Labour Party since 1935 I mean
it's quite something I mean Jeremy
Corbyn can't stay on Tony the thing is
is that elections and politics is pretty
bruising and when you're going through
me and when you pull all of your heart
and soul into an election campaign to
then turn around and be faced with the
possibility of leaves in your seat it is
really hard and tough and I think that
you know we've really got a I've got to
thank all of the labor supporters have
been out there that have worked this if
if Labour have actually really seriously
lost 71 seats Jeremy Corbyn calm stays
leader can wife lost 71 seats it will be
absolutely devastating and you know I
also just bringing the recent record
with John Bercow who sat there watching
it all you know you lose one election
you tend to stand out Gordon Brown will
David Cameron lost er lost a referendum
you go this would be two elections
because let's not forget Jeremy Corbyn
lost the last election as well kind of
almost spun it as a victory but I mean
could you imagine him staying on
well the Labour Party will have to make
a decision about that for itself and I'm
quite certain that it's something - it's
Jeremy Thorpe him will give thought he's
a well of reflecting always already I
don't know but it seems to me that you
know that's a judgment for the Labour
Party certainly the result if it is
as foreshadowed by the exit poll is just
as a matter of fact the worst result for
the Labour Party for a very very very
long time I think I'm right in saying in
1983 labour got 200 - 909 with myself
you know less but let's stay with little
ship and flip it round on Butler do you
want him to stay do you still see him as
as an asset Joey Corbin you know I think
just so early on in the evening I think
we really have to wait and then we
really have to reflect quite seriously
about where we go and the direction of
travel for the Labour Party but I think
it's just too early in the evening to be
talking about that to be honest I agree
with that because a political party in
the face of a defeat has to have a
debate and although of course is an
absolutely natural media reaction to
want to see a scalp scalp I mean just
dealing I mean we're in a party what the
policies might be in the future just in
different directions - no but John it's
about the numbers if they are the
numbers you should comes in and we're
seeing this direction of Michael's can I
drink can I just cause Sam Sam Cates is
my colleagues just tweeted this out
about the pattern for labour it's not
just about brexit he's saying from the
exit poll he extrapolated out it looks
like labor down everywhere in both leave
and remain votes in areas so that is not
just about bricks it also is about
during the Corbin's leadership isn't it
but it can also be about how we
portrayed brexit for a long time that's
just a brexit issue there's something
out you still but you still can though
because people on both sides we were
trying to unite argument again about
road to travel has been misled been
gullible no no that's not what I'm
saying at all what I'm saying is that
our position in the labour party for a
long time people who kept saying we
don't understand your position and that
that would have affected how people
thought about did you find out you
renegotiated in three months and then
have a referendum did you find it
difficult for people to get their head
round that what precisely you were
offering well I was very clear on my
positions because I was very clear that
I wanted to remain in the European Union
but also very clear that
we did we still need to I mean let's not
forget we still you need to relight and
reunite and unite the country and I
don't think that this result is
essentially going to do that so I think
that in a you know in by the end of you
know this week we're still going to be
talking about what happens next and with
the countries still going to be very
divided don't if you can stay with us
because Beth referring there we're
communicating with sound coats through
Twitter well we can sound a sound really
interesting just take us through some of
those numbers in if gone but we'll stay
and we'll have a look at those Sam of
course Dermot so we've been crunching
the numbers and looking at the different
trends up and down the country using the
exit poll mainly with my colleague will
Jennings and we found something quite
stark when it comes to the conservative
vote there you see the Conservatives
doing better clearly doing better in
areas that voted to leave more strongly
but when it comes to the Labour vote
well as you've been seeing from all of
what eight results that we've had so far
it's down pretty uniformly whether it
was a leave seat or a remain seat and
that's just a complication for those in
the labour party who are trying to pin
tonight's bad results as John McDonnell
was on breakfast Dermott okay well Don
Butler answer that what do you put it
down to then leave that and remain seats
so far you write early days but on the
hard and fast facts that we've got so
far
you're not appealing to anyone but I
still think it's to do with the
messaging you know at the end of the day
you know I can easily concede that the
Conservatives had a very clear message
okay but what about your message and who
formulated that that would be the reason
wasn't as clear as it could have been
and should have been what we've got to
admit that we have to admit that but
don't you have yeah but it was the lead
it was about the leadership as well I
mean Jeremy Corbyn went into this
election the most unpopular leader since
Pollan began he did pick up a bit but
his polling ratings were terrible you
must be able to recognize that he was
part of the block on labor in this
election and and and has to take
responsibility for this performance if
that is correct that poll well Jeremy is
the leaders
so of course he would have to take
responsibility that's what the leader
role is is to take responsibility for
the team or might that take well as I
said you know it's not something I mean
I've never been a kind of person when
you know when labor Lawson 20 I've never
said oh you know Gordon Brown has to
resign that's not the person that I am I
think that we have to reflect the
direction of travel and where we go and
we have to take an approach about that
you know I'm not gonna sit on here and
say oh yes such as such as ago that's
not that's not the way I think we should
conduct politics and I think the lesson
from this election is that we really
need to do politics differently and we
need to be a little bit more measured
and we need control for 15 years she's
loyal to the labor tribe and loyal to
her core and being the law of person she
is I wouldn't expect her for one moment
to call for the resignation of her
leader the lack of appeal of Jeremy
Corwin but it could also be the
messaging as dawn Buffy was saying they
get brexit done
pure and simple message you know
renegotiate and then never have a
referendum at some point it's a bit more
complicated it could have been that and
the point you have not you could well
have been that yeah I mean the clarity
and starkness of the conservative
message manifestly has resonated now the
fact that is resonated because there was
a slogan that resonated doesn't
necessarily mean that that message is
correct what it means is that that
message has worked for now and it
certainly does appear to work don't
detract from her but it doesn't mean
that the message itself is necessarily
correct in all its particular okay
listen we're gonna get back to Scott and
talk don't but let's thank you very much
indeed for coming in and we leave you to
go and reflect and consider what the
future holds perhaps for the leader and
indeed for the party very good to see
Don but listen we're gonna Scotland as I
say and tommy Shepherd is the SNP
candidate for Edinburgh East and let's
check in first of all Tommy Shepherd on
how you're feeling do you think you're
going to become the the MP for Edinburgh
East again
I hope so comets good morning from
Edinburgh it's looking quite good innit
Mauritius and certainly have the first
time ever just with the SNP has won the
postal ballot which is not something
we've ever done before so it all goes
well for a big night ahead okay and we
have to get straight into the issue of a
referendum and independence referendum
as well on the exit poll no results in
yet in Scotland of course but um that's
exit poll 55 seats that would be right
back up towards the 2015 performance
what what does that mean for an
independence referendum in your view at
this point in time I'm taking the exit
poll with a big pinch of salt until we
can see some hard results that exit poll
is not in line with other polls during
the campaign it's not aligned with our
own data so it would be quite a
surprising and short result where it to
be true we're contesting 59 seats in
Scotland if we win 30 or more of them
then we will regard that as a victory
and it looks as if we're on course to do
a lot better than that and in answer to
your question about the referendum
Dermot we put three propositions before
people in this election one was to lock
Boris Johnson out of government two was
to escape brexit and three was to assert
the right of people here to choose their
own form of government and it does look
as if we've received a resounding
endorsement of all three propositions so
yeah we're on Wow no to pursue that
mandate with the UK government and it's
for them to decide what they want to do
about it
yeah but but one and two aren't going to
happen that's for sure on that exit poll
what how does three happen though how'd
you get that pass Boris Johnson and
Westminster after legislate to allow it
well that's if the people of Scotland
have spoken very loudly and firmly to
with one voice saying that they do
believe that whether or not Scotland
should choose it a former government
should be a matter for the people here
and that's the principle we've been
trying to establish in this campaign I'm
not expecting Boris Johnson to suddenly
support Scottish independence we've
simply been saying that when and whether
there is another referendum that should
be a matter for people in Scotland and
for the elected Scottish Parliament not
for Westminster I would hope that he
might want to listen in the morning to
to that voice and if he doesn't then
frankly I don't know how many more
mandates we have to get before he will
okay Tommy Shepherd thank you very much
indeed I will let you go and find out
how you've done there it's going to be
returned to Westminster let's get more
now from our correspondents since the
election counts tonight so many dotted
across the UK there are some crucial
results jus from across the Midlands
that's for sure skies Martha Kellner
is in Fenton that's near stoke-on-trent
Martin brunt come back Martin is in
Chesterfield and Dominic Waghorn is in
Birmingham well let's go to Martha first
now stoke-on-trent three seats there one
of them was in conservative hands what
about the other two yeah it's been a
huge battleground during this election
as you said three seats being counted
here stoke-on-trent south central and
north as you mentioned stoke-on-trent
South he's already in conservative hands
Jack Brereton one DC in 2017 he became
the first conservative conservative
elected to be elected here since the
1930s but the Conservatives tonight are
hopeful of taking those other two seats
and in fact I've just been speaking to
the Labour incumbent and the Stoke and
Stoke central Gareth's nel and he's
incredibly dejected
he says if those exit polls are correct
and if there's 71 seats gone he's
convinced that his will be one of those
and he is furious with Jeremy Corbyn he
says these traditional labour heartlands
have been completely neglected and he
says in many ways this is an election
decided along brexit lines but it's also
a failure of leadership he says
he's calling for Jeremy Corbyn to go and
but we'll get a clearer picture here
once the declarations are made we're
expecting around 4 to 5 a.m. this
morning ok Martha thank you very much
indeed you are Martin bronty's in
Chesterfield we're amongst others the
Bolsover count is taking place will tell
us about boss over and Dennis Skinner
well people bandy around the phrase the
end of an era if the predictions are
right and the tourists have taken this
from Dennis Skinner and that phrase
really would apply he's been the MP here
for 49 years this has always been a
Labour seat
they say round here come election time
that if you put up a Jack Russell and
pinned a red rosette to it it would win
for labour there's no sign of mr.
Skinner yet and as you can probably see
Dermot we're not being allowed into the
counting hall so mr. Skinner's not here
the the Tory candidate Mark Fletcher the
grandson of a minor he won't talk to us
either
I think perhaps although everybody is
aware of the predicted results it may go
down to the wire so nobody really wants
to come and talk to us officially at at
this stage but we've got a long time to
go this is a very rural area the votes
have taken a long time to get here and
we probably won't get a result
come confirmation of that predicted
result until about 4:30 ok Martin thank
you very much indeed you say that's a
very rural area let's go to a very urban
area don't eat my corn there in
Birmingham and two seats in particular
where we're looking out there we're
hearing from that exit poll anyway
Dominic Addington Jack drom ease seats
and Northfield both leave leaning
constituencies that's right Irma and
being Britain's second biggest city a
lot of votes to count here so an even
longer night for us possibly waiting
until 6:30 or 7:00 in the morning
possibly if you look at what has
happened in previous elections here
this isn't Newcastle with Sunderland
it's a it's a slower steadier rate of
County
so may have a long wait before we find
out exactly what has happened here there
are 10 constituencies in Birmingham
several of them being counted here three
of them in their constituencies it voted
by a whisker I think 50.4% in favor of
leave but despite that I think labour
had been hopeful that all its nine seats
here would remain in their hands but as
you say there are concerns about two
seats in particular earnings in Jeremy's
seat the exit polls are suggesting
that's touch-and-go as to whether he's
going to retain his seat in Northfield
Richard burden that looks like according
to the exit poll at least that that will
go to the Conservatives which would be
quite an upset here
of course Andrew Mitchell is the only MP
Conservative MP who has a seat in
Birmingham he's likely to retain his
seat so that red wall that we've heard
about crumbling may well crumble as far
south as Birmingham and there's been
some reaction to that from Jess Phillips
who even though her constituency voted
in favor of leaving in the brexit
referendum she looks like she will be
safe she has a pretty firm majority in
the exit poll doesn't suggest that she's
going to lose it
but she has been reacting with I would
say a sort of air of despondency on
Twitter on Twitter to this evening
two hours ago saying there are very few
words for how heartbroken I am for the
community our represents who have been
through enough and then an hour ago she
tweeted it feels like a punch in the
stomach we will all be thinking of the
harm that could be done to those we care
for she's interesting of course because
if Jeremy Corbyn does resigned in the
wake of this of these results then she
is one of those expected or likely to or
seen as a possible contender for his job
ok listen thank you all we'll be back
with you all for the results as they
come in just to alert our viewers to
another count with keeping the closer
I'm going to talk to John Bercow in a
moment once Becky and Lavery the Labour
Party chair sitting on in the last
Parliament's a majority round about the
10,000 mark another seat in the
northeast just north of Newcastle we are
told that it's close they're on a they
are going to a recount their inlay
perhaps in some difficulties therefore
the Labour Party John Bercow as you saw
there a special guest for the evening
the former Speaker what do you think
John Burke about this let's talk
personally yeah you know you you often
described there as the man who partially
was helping those backbench MP s bloc
brexit I mean it looks like brexit is
definitely gonna happen in the form that
Boris Johnson has termed it personal
feelings on that well I always saw it as
my role dermis as Speaker to stand up
for the rights of members individually
and of the house institutionally it
wasn't the job of the speaker for
example to get brexit done or indeed to
stop brexit getting done it was for the
speaker
to allow the house to breathe to allow
members to say what they wanted to allow
the House of Commons to debate the
motions and subjects of its choice
so when members came to me and said we
want to debate XYZ motion or we're keen
to support a particular amendment to a
government motion my instinct was to be
permissive and to say yes if that is the
will that his perfectly proper that
should happen that should proceed and
then in terms of what the outcome was
well that's a question of what the
numbers were the speaker doesn't vote
unless as a tie I had to vote once and I
voted for the first time in my
speakership but I wasn't making
decisions about policy I was simply
saying yes the house should have an are
you making you're making decisions and
you know you were there controversial
decisions about the rules and I mean
centuries of precedent in one case
overruling that with the when you said
that well how do we set a precedent if
we don't overturn well do you think you
went too far no I said did I think I
went too far at all first of all in one
case I was trying to protect the house
from being frankly berated her and and
intimidated into voting for something
which it made it very clear it didn't
want namely that ariza may withdrawal
agreement and I invoked precedent
and the precedent was very very very
long established that the house
shouldn't be asked repeatedly to
pronounce on something where it had
already made a decision the houses
decisions matter they needed to be
respected and they shouldn't constantly
be returned to day after day after day
on the principle oh well if you don't
like it we're just going to keep beating
you over the head a third or fourth or
fifth six time until you do as we the
executive the government say so there I
was invoking precedent to protect the
house there were instances in which I
said well precedent isn't the only guide
if we were guided exclusively by
precedent manifestly nothing would ever
change and I made that point when if
memory serves me correctly in January of
this year I simply allowed an amendment
from a former Attorney General and I
absolutely stand by this to a government
motion to be debated and voted on by the
house and I remember the government
Chief Whip saying to me mr. speaker you
will not dictate what happens in this
place and I said Tim Julian with a very
greatest respect I'm not seeking to
dictate what happens in this place what
I'm saying that house should yes I know
you didn't know what you were deciding
was controversial you you had some some
rouse in that chamber as well do you
have some rouse in the chamber if the
Speaker of the House of Commons is going
to be a craven lickspittle of the
executive branch it's just going to be
pushed hither and thither and told what
to do that person frankly will be like a
floating cork in a fast stream of water
that would be an absurd state of vests
if the speaker is going to be browbeaten
and instructed what to do that person
isn't doing did you pay more I mean
maybe it was July job does that mean the
Parliament but did you did you pick more
on that on the brexit it's I mean Andrea
led some you had some very happily deal
with that let me deal with the two
points first of all on the issue of
brexit the truth of the matter is if you
look back over the years the consistent
thread in my speakership was that I
stood up for the rights of minorities to
be heard when the
tears were in the minority on the
conservative side in fact before the
word brexit ear had even been coined
they were known as Euroskeptics I
consistently gave them their head I
selected urgent questions from Bill cash
and Bernhard jenkin John redwood and
others because I thought the government
needed to be probed questions
scrutinized challenged and so on and I
remember saying to burn a Genk in quite
recently when he was really something of
a moaning Minnie grumbling at me when I
was making decisions that suited you
you weren't moaning the reason why
you're grumbling is that you don't like
the decisions being made now I treated
the bricks of tears in a fair way and I
treated the remainders in a fair way and
that's for here led some well Andrea was
perfectly entitled to her view she
didn't have a very strong grasp of
parliamentary procedure and she was
entitled her opinion but she suffered
from the rather material disadvantage of
being wrong but you do accept don't you
think we were one of the most
controversial speakers of modern times
indeed of parliamentary times I mean
there's also there's also the question
John about your personal relations with
your staff those allegations of bullying
I mean it was incredibly controversial
what do you answer to those I answer to
those as follows first I've never
bullied anyone in any way to any degree
in any situation at any time is you'd a
straightforward rebuttal it is not true
second I would emphasize that you could
just look at the facts I had several
people in my office who worked for me
for year after year after year the
speaker secretary Peter Barrett who
served me loyally in that role for eight
and a half years served with me in the
speaker's office in total for ten his
deputy likewise eight and a half years
as deputy to the speaker's Factory and
there was investigation that never
really took place the sense was that it
was being swept under the carpet
well city not by me absolutely wasn't
swept under the carpet by me it was for
the house to make a judgement about what
the procedure should be and if somebody
wanted to come forward and make a
complaint he or she should have the
opportunity to do so the particular
point I want to members
is this and I hope that this will
resonate with people across the country
in the course of a working life you
would certainly hope that most of your
working relationships succeed 70 percent
or more is perhaps not a bad guiding
light some working relationships fail
and a very very very small number of
mine in the early years did that doesn't
prove that one person maltreated another
what it proves is that it wasn't the
right fit it didn't work I have
extremely harmonious relations both with
my Buckingham constituency parliamentary
office staff and with the speaker's
office staff and I think if I may say so
the proof of the pudding is meeting when
I stood down a speaker I had staff from
the past making contact saying they
wanted to come back ok so the last Prime
Minister's question they wouldn't be
doing that if I were some sort of ogre
and what about well will you become a
lord let me put it that way yeah what
about this a former speaker a nice
custome isn't it to get appearance do
you think you will be denied one and if
you are do you think it's going to be
pettiness well we'll have to wait would
you like one yes if I'm offered it I'll
take it it has been the very
long-established practice that a former
Speaker of the House leaves the house
after ceasing to be speaker and tends to
go to the House of Lords so if I'm
offered the opportunity to serve in the
House of Lords I say to you an
equivocally that I will take it I'm not
sitting awake at night worrying about it
I'm not losing sleep
it isn't ultimately for me to decide
it's for others to judge and I will have
to rest content with whatever the
outcome is but look the way I put it you
is this none of us is without floor to
err is human
I made my fair share of mistakes I tried
to get the big strategic judgments about
conduct and atmosphere and opportunity
in the chamber right and decisions right
about how the parliamentary estate
should be run I've no plans to die
tomorrow but if I were to die tomorrow
I'd die happy thinking I've been
incredibly lucky I had a wonderful
experience and I'm very grateful to the
house but on that desire for a period I
mean I asked you earlier about the
future so it might not be over for you
if you did get one Pollock
it might not be over for you you'd be an
active member of the of the House of
Lords would you if you get that peerage
well I mentioned to you earlier that one
of my early challenges is to overcome my
natural shyness reticence and
self-effacement I mean if I feel that I
can overcome that innate caution and
disinclination to express myself and I
were in a forum
okay that was YouTube chamber that gave
me the chance to speak would I sit well
what mentees would you sit on as well
having you Conservative MP would you sit
on the conservative benches if you did
get a pitch ordinarily the speaker if
the speak against the Lord's goes to the
Lords of crossbench in here so I
wouldn't expect to go on the basis that
you're suggesting as a conservative I
left the Conservative Party on the night
of 22nd of June 2009 in conformity with
convention because I was elected the
speaker and the house expects the
speaker to be independent of and
unconnected with party politics back to
politics this evening and these results
starting to come in John Berger thanks
very much indeed for that but you're not
going yet you're not going anywhere for
many hours yet because you are watching
the brexit election on Sky News it is
threat I can't see the clock the cameras
covering it three minutes past but to
engross them John Berger the headline so
far and the first few results are in
conservatives have gained a seat in the
Northeast Bligh Valley and there they've
held on in Swindon north with a bigger
majority just in Paul the Conservative
Party candidates 32,000
[Applause]
and I've been shot results for labor in
the northeast in Sunderland central
labor holding the seat but with a much
reduced majority of just under 3000 and
these results that we've had so far many
more to come of course they are in line
with this exit poll for Sky News the BBC
and ITV News that predicted the
Conservative Party will win the general
election with 368 seats that would mean
a majority of 86 for Boris Johnson
labour support has been projected to go
down everywhere in both leave and remain
leaning seats The Shadow Chancellor John
McDonnell told us appropriate decisions
would be made about jeremy corbyn's
future and after the exit poll Boris
Johnson thank voters on Twitter saying
we live in the greatest democracy in the
world a declaration now in the West
Midlands one of the first is the seat of
Nuneaton as you can see they're voted
leave let's listen in at the above
election do hereby give notice that the
numbers recorded to each candidate at
the said election is as follows
frightfully noisy Richard Adrian Liberal
Democrats 1862 Jones
Marcus Charles the Conservative Party
candidate 27,000 319 conduct Keith Anton
Green Party 1692 main Zoe Christie
Labour Party 14200
46 the number of ballot papers rejected
was as follows
one top official mark zero voting for
more candidates very neat Turner a
conservative seats after the easy last
election but a big majority now for
Marcus Jones an increased majority up
there to thirteen thousand one hundred
and forty four from around about four
thousand seven hundred last time around
so a big increase and a big push back
again for the Labour Party you must
remember that this actually was a fairly
marginal seat four years ago or so and
the Labour Party pushed back to fourteen
thousand or so votes it is a and leave
tending seat one voted to leave in the
European Union referendum in 2016 but
John Bercow I say back to business look
at that increase in vote chair for the
Conservative Party 60% of the vote there
in what was once it's not anymore a
marginal seat in the labour vote down
there about 10 percent yes it's very
striking in Marcus Jones has tripled his
majority and to put it in context as you
rightly said it has been a marginal seat
and that includes having previously been
a Labour see Marcus Jones has been the
Member of Parliament since 2010 but no
way would any wouldn't ordinarily
characterize it as a safe seat it's not
the sort of seat Dermot where the
benefit of your viewers that one would
expect to see a 60% share of the vote
going either to the conservative all to
the Labour candidate so obviously it is
a commentary on the campaign and no
doubt to some degree also on the British
news efforts of Marcus Jones yeah he's
got up to 60% of the vote political
editor Barry Barry we're seeing this now
it's patently still early days but the
exit poll we're seeing this pattern of
the conservative vote going up all over
the place all parts of the United
Kingdom their ever reported self yeah
that's right I mean look what what's
happened is it has been there was a
frame in battle if you like between
labour and the Conservatives labour
wanted this to be the NHS the austerity
the cost of living election Boris
Johnson his three lines strapped get
bricks
dan had the vote leave team from the
22nd 16 referendum in his camp you
remember their slogan of 2016 that also
won that referendum take back control a
very simple slogan and and tonight what
what it is clear is that if there was
any hope of turning this into a
different sort of election from Labour
they have won sorry they have lost and
they have lost definitively and that red
wall isn't just wobbly and I mean it's
been obliterated it's almost yeah so I
get the reference that was a polystyrene
wall roller this one is well not brick
specter made of MPs and it does seem
that if the exit poll is to be believed
it is going to tumble tonight the
prediction there the Conservative Party
will have a majority of 86 and DOMA now
let me bring in the green party's
co-leader Jonathan Bartley in
Westminster if this does turn out to be
the case a majority of 86 for Boris
Johnson and the Conservatives in Boris
Johnson's
terms brexit is happening the UK will
leave the European Union at the end of
January well we didn't vote for this
election we didn't want this election we
warned that something like this might
happen and it's a deeply disappointing
night I think for all progressive
parties but it is labour that I've lost
this but what it does reveal is that
Boris Johnson will have a 60 70 seat
majority whatever it turns out to be in
the House of Commons and nights young
but we'll find out in due course but
won't have achieved 50 percent of the
vote in this country which again
underlies the need I think for electoral
reform we've constantly reached out to
other progressive parties to work with
us they've rebuffed us and as long as
Labour continues to refuse to back
proportional representation it will
always just be lining up the next
Conservative government even when the
Conservative government fails to get 50
percent of the vote in this country
let's just stay with the system we've
got and you said well we didn't vote for
this general election well to be fair to
labour they were reluctant and it was
really the the Lib Dems your colleagues
in the room
Alliance did they let the site down no I
mean labor posted full square for this
general election it took him a couple of
attempts but then they went for it and
they believed that they could win it and
we thought that was a very reckless
thing to do certainly with the Liberal
Democrats we agreed with them about
remaining in the European Union we still
feel that's the best thing for the
future of the country but of course we
disagree with them on a lot of things
and we disagreed with them about calling
this general election at that point and
I don't know if you've been talking to
your colleagues have stood up and down
the United Kingdom but do you go along
with this exit poll prediction one seat
Caroline Lucas one imagines what we're
going to see I think a big swing in
somewhere like Bristol West so we'll see
what the night holds I think that count
is a long way to go still but we'll have
to wait and wait see in due course okay
and what about the other thing the
Greens stand for in the name of the
party of course do you think I mean your
vote sure looking it's early days isn't
it of course we've been looking at you
virtually a ticking up a percentage
point or two in some of those
constituencies do you think that's also
an endorsement there of your
environmental warnings I think it is
we of course doubled our number of
councillors this year we've doubled a
number of MEP s in the European
Parliament it looks like we might just
double our vote share in this election
clearly the climate was front and center
for us and the climate emergency is the
thing that we've got to hold this
government's feet to the fire about but
let's be under no illusions this is a
very very bad result for the climate
emergency this is a bad bad night for
our future security and I think we
should need to take this result very
very seriously and we need opposition
MPs from right across the parties
holding this government's feet to the
fire about this and not get diverted
simply on the issue of brexit because
this is a bigger issue it's a more
important issue we've been proud to have
you know led the agenda and push the
other parties in the right direction but
the spotlight must not now fall off the
climate emergency okay but I mean is it
a bad day for the climate emergency as
you put it the Tories have legislated
haven't they to go net carbon zero by by
2050 shouldn't you Emily
talking about healing the country and
bringing it back together shouldn't you
work with them obviously we'll work with
them where those common ground but if
they're road-building expanding airports
continuing fossil fuel subsidies if
they're going to continue to block wind
power on shore wind that is no way to
tackle the climate emergency I don't
think this government has any real sense
of the kind of change that we have to
make it isn't even including aviation
and shipping emissions in its own
targets targets incidentally which are
too late and which it already on track
to miss it fails on every single measure
when it comes to the climate emergency
okay Chandler Bartley thank you very
much indeed very good to talk to you
right more results expected very soon
significant results for this Labour
Party performance we're expecting
results coming in from Warrington very
soon and Caterina vertice is in Wrexham
in Wales for us and I say there they're
very important in Endor Brady is in
Workington there and in part this
election apartment being the brexit
election Endor was termed as the battle
for Workington a seat that the Tories
have really targeted yes they have and
they're sounding very very confident a
declaration is imminent here Dermot this
constituency has been labour for 97 of
the past 100 years and the Conservatives
really did target the seats we know of
course the phrase Workington man was
trotted out by this right-leaning
think-tank early in the campaign and
Workington man was identified as a and
northern labour leave voter in rugby
league towns like Workington who could
possibly be swayed by Boris Johnson's
mantra of get Bragg's it Don and just
looking around the room the
Conservatives are here they're eating
pizza they're smiling and they feel very
very confident indeed this will be
absolutely seismic if they were to win
here this having been a Labour
constituency as I say a Labour seat for
97 of the past
100 years we've had the turnout figures
through already 67 point nine four
percent turnout declaration just a few
minutes away a most unlikely bellwether
town really working Tangier in northern
Cumbria labour last time round had a
majority of just under four thousand and
they're looking quite low at the moment
conservatives are smiling as I say
eating pizza awaiting the declaration
and we'll know in a few minutes time
okay keep an eye on it for a sender but
in the meantime let's set check in with
Catarina Batak see they're in Wrexham
this red wall talking about it starts
there in north east Wales and a slim
labour majority there yes it was really
the slimmest of margins only 1800 votes
in it between labour and the
Conservatives in 2017 and I can tell you
that when those initial exit polls came
out at 10 o'clock there are a number of
people gathered in the 4a area of the
Sports Hall whether the count is
underway and it was palpable the sense
of shock just seeing those numbers I
think it really dawned on people here
who already knew that Wrexham was a
marginal that it was a tight seat that
this would likely be one of those areas
where a labour seat could for the first
time since 1935 turn blue the
Conservative candidate for Wrexham Sarah
Atherton has been wandering around
listening and having watching the vote
counts happening here they are feeling
extremely confident there are some very
glum labour faces in this hall behind me
it's really quite a seismic shift if it
does go the way that the exit polls
suggest and and if it goes away that
certainly the conservative activists
here think that it eventually will go
towards that conservative when seismic
when you think no Wrexham is the town of
miners it's the town of steel workers
for generations labour is all that
people here have
we'll know probably in about 40 minutes
or so whether that will change for the
first time since 1935 okay keep an eye
on it Caterina thank you very much do we
know you will got to talk now to the
deputy chairman of the Conservative
Party Paul Scully and Paul Scully just
I'm sure you're aware we're keeping an
eye on these declarations Workington
you'll be very interested to hear so we
might break in but then we will come
back to you for reaction but are you
daring to dream now on this exit poll
and the results we've seen so far it
looks like a remarkably good night for
the Conservatives and some well I mean
obviously this is a projection but it's
encouraging certainly I think it's
testament to the amount of work that
candidates up and down the country have
been doing it's testament to the simple
message that Boris and the Conservative
government have been putting out there
that you know getting brexit done leaves
means that we have a parliament that
will better reflect the people showing
clear leadership clear direction and
that's what people have been crying out
for for 3/9 years to make sure that we
can get on to talk about police they
fifty thousand more nurses and and
funding a leveling up our funding for
education well you say it was a simple
message we accept that get brexit done
but do you think you're really leveled
with people that it's going to be a
complex process to untangle a 46 year or
so relationship I think the process is
undoubtedly complex but the simple
message was we we need to get on with it
we need to focus on how we're leaving
with the e the EU and not getting bogged
down with whether we're leaving with the
the the EU which we settled
three-and-a-half years ago so now
hopefully although there will be
differences in the debate about our
future relationship we can hopefully
come down to a narrower focus of that
building that trading relationship and
getting that negotiation right with the
EU so that we can both sets the EU and
the UK can prosper in years to come
but also unlock the domestic agenda as
well okay well what's the priority for
you just as there we keep an eye on more
counts that sir
that's Darby but Paul Scully what what
is the priority for you after the gap
Breck sig done presumably that means
January the 31st what
want to see is the symbol of delivery
for these it looks like hundreds of
thousands maybe millions of people who
are voting for the Conservative Party
who haven't voted for them before what's
going to say to them in policy terms
what's going to say to them we hear you
we understand you well first thing is as
I say is just getting there that
referendum result are enacted so we're
leaving but also I think that it's
delivering things that they can actually
tangibly see that actually improve their
outcomes health outcomes standards and
skills more policemen on the street to
make them feel safer it's these key
things it's not getting bogged down with
a race on theoretical policies or just
telephone numbers when it comes to
budgets it's what money that money can
actually deliver for people when they go
to their hospital their schools and look
in their streets for the policeman but
the point is you know you talk about
improving health outcomes more police on
the streets I mean that takes years as
well recruiting and training up all it
does I'm saying undoubtedly it does yes
it did but you know so what's going to
show them pretty soon that the
Conservatives hear them that's a
different Conservative Party from the
one that generations perhaps in their
family have said we we won't touch them
with a bargepole
well we've already started recruiting
the 20,000 new policemen we've got
record amount of GPS in training at the
moment but as you say I'm doubting takes
time to get them through training and
we've got to get that first batch
through the policeman on the streets the
doctors actually in the GP surgeries and
in hospital departments as well to make
sure that when we're talking about 50
million new UK appointments people can
actually see that okay Paul Scalia I'm
cutting across you because there's a
result coming that perhaps you might
want to hear I'm sure it is working to
be discussing sue Heyman was the MP
their shadow cabinet member for the
Labour Party also let alone you we've
got a lot of w's going on here
Workington they're about to declare one
spec you may have remembered if you've
been with us that I mentioned before Ian
Lavery the Labour Chairman we are told
is
declare fairly soon it oh I and receipt
he has been here since for the
Workington constituency do he died
hereby declare that the total number of
votes cast for each candidate was as
follows
Coburn Nikki independent 842 Heyman sooo
Labour Party sixteen thousand three
hundred and twelve huge Neil Liberal
Democrat 1525 ivanson Roy Allen
eighty-seven Jenkinson mark the
Conservative Party twenty thousand
[Applause]
[Music]
20,000 488 Perry Jill green party 596
Walker David brexit party 1749 well
there we have it working turn tumbling
as anybody on the spot they was telling
us working to learn was one of the
phrases going for this election a
conservative game from labor they did
have a majority the Labour Party did
have a majority of 4,000 that's been
almost identically reversed by mark
Jenkinson putting the Conservatives in
there with a majority four thousand 176
sue Heyman shadow cabinets member
ejected from Parliament's and vote chair
let's take you through them her vote
chair that fell quite considerably you
know by at least four thousand share 39%
there this change in chair is perhaps
the most interesting of the evening as
the Conservatives start picking up these
seats that Labour used to be incredibly
strong it up seven and a half percent
lay back down in eleven point nine
percent the brexit party a performance
their four point two percent some coats
are deputy political editor is putting
all these into his database and reading
what it tells us and what it tells us
some even from down here is is that this
exit poll is looking pretty accurate
absolutely Dermot that's increasingly
clear we are on course for a majority
around the range of the 86 that we saw
in the exit poll at ten o'clock just
look at the swing in that seat of
Workington Workington has been labor
since 1979 now there's been a swing from
the Labor Party to the Conservatives in
the region of ten percent um if you look
the Tories now have around fifty percent
of the vote in that seat and that was
that was what the Labour Party got in
the 2017 elections so now there's a
whopping
4,000 majority in this what was once an
absolute labor heartland so I think that
will be perhaps the result this evening
that has stung the Labour Party the most
if we want to look at one other result
um in Lavery
the Labour Party Chairman there were
rumors that he might even lose his seat
he has hung on but by only the slimmest
of margins we had that result in the
last few minutes and there his majority
has gone down from 10,000 at this
election to 814 again swaying in the
region of about seven eight percent from
Labour to the Conservatives in Lavery
will be glad to have hung on but that
kind of decline in his support in his in
his seat will sting whether it means he
doesn't run for the deputy leadership or
not will remain to be seen okay we're
just looking at that result in fault Sam
thank you very much indeed for the
analysis and back there to working to in
a son was saying there I'm getting there
first Conservative MP for 40 years there
the shadow Environment Secretary sue
Haman losing a seat I think we might be
able to hear us speaking in a moment or
two yes sir she is apparently conceding
up on the platform there and working -
let's have a listen he stayed with me
for the whole four years that I've been
a member of parliament I'd like to thank
my agent my campaign team who have
worked so hard and I'd also like to
thank my husband thank you well just
disappointed to him in their shadow
Environment Secretary losing seat
another gain for the Conservatives in
these formerly strong labour seats also
seeing at the bottom of your screen
they're worth keeping an eye on there
the results are beginning to pick up the
SNP with their first gained in Scotland
now this exit poll predicting that
they'll get 55 seats obviously going to
be some gains there if the exit poll is
correct SNP leader Nicola Sturgeon these
you can see they're saying it's gonna be
a good night for a party well gained
rather Glen and Hamilton from Labour
let's go to Darlington
another key seat for labour let's see
how the Conservatives are doing
good evening ladies and gentlemen I live
swim have been the acting turning
officer for the election of a member of
parliament for the constituency of
Darlington do you hereby give notice the
number of votes recorded for each
candidate at the said election is as
follows Branch Kevin John independent
292 Chapman Jennifer Labour Party 17,000
607 Carrie Anne Murray Liberal Democrats
2097 Gibson Peter Alexander the
Conservative Party candidate 20,000
[Applause]
Wrexham party 1544 snicker Matthew
Charles Green Party candidate 1,057 the
total number of spar ballot papers was
81 the turnout was sixty five point six
three percent and I do hereby declare
that Peter Alexander Gibson is to be
elected
well my goodness me Darlington falling
now to this conservative advance into
labour areas now you may remember in
2017 this was a seat that the
Conservatives tried very hard to take
away from labour that to resume strategy
which is kind of a pre echo of what
Boris Johnson has done in his doing at
this evening but they've gained it this
time Peter Gibson elected there for the
Conservative Party taking out Jenny
Chapman her majority well her vote says
you don't have a majority anymore did
have a majority 3280 number of votes
went down by about 5,000 the first time
a conservative is God in there since
1992 let's have a look at the first
result we were mentioning there from
Scotland and this Rutherglen in Hamilton
West and SNP gained
the other feature of the exit poll this
evening is suggesting as Nicola Sturgeon
is saying at the bottom of your screen
quoted as saying good night for the SNP
as well does this begin to prove it a
gain from the labour party it swapped
hands in 2017 labour took it from the
SNP they've taken it back in the form of
Margaret Faria with a twenty three
thousand seven hundred and seventy five
labour pushed back down there to 18
thousand five hundred and forty five
this is the share then we show you the
change the SNP up to forty four point
two percent that's a a big gain given
the way that seat has flip-flopped to
7.2% up labour down three point one
percent the Conservatives down four
point six percent and Lib Dems more or
less level pegging John Burke who you
wanted to say something about Rutherglen
yell well simply to say that that's a
return for Margaret Faria she was one of
the people who came in in 2015 she was
in fact ubiquitous presence in the House
of Commons jumping up and down every day
I remember very well she was an
immensely active member but she lost in
2017 now she's back and with a
significant interesting that I want to
talk to Beth Rigby though about so
what's been going on in Workington
Darlington as well Beth Ruby I keep
going back to it because we still have
not very many results but my goodness I
mean it could be dare I use the word
bloodbath for labour it keeps going it's
beginning to feel that way isn't it and
look labour tried to have this jewel
strategy on for exit where they faced
both remaining seats in their
metropolitan areas such as London and
Manchester and then they also tried to
have a vote leave element by saying that
they would have this referendum and
there would be a choice between a Labour
brexit and remaining in the EU and they
they tried to straddle both these camps
because they wanted to try and keep some
of these vote leaves seats but it just
appears like they are falling like
dominoes and that strategy has totally
failed and comprehensively failed and
there will be a lot of soul-searching I
imagine
whether that was the royally is to be
I'm going to be talking to the shadow
justice circular he Richard Bergen from
the Labour Party in a moment or two
we're hearing he's suspend lined up as
we say but there's an awful lot for Edie
Conway to take us through about how the
night is panning out for both the main
parties Edie yet come down and have a
look at this I mean here on our map and
you can see there the school board
evolving you wouldn't normally see as
many conservative seats as you see there
I mean normally most of those sees early
declare is tend to be in the Northeast
you tend to get a lot of Labor around
now but just have a look at that map the
map of Britain the political map
changing there you can see brother kind
of Hamilton in the first Scottish seat
just there and just look Northwest you
can see Workington a lot of seats there
in the Northeast many of them still
staying with labour but you're seeing
across much of the Northeast swings
around ten percent or so from labor to
the Conservative Party and over the
course of the evening that map will get
filled in and we will show you just how
the political geography of this country
is starting to change it certainly looks
like it's changing it certainly feels
like it's changing at the moment and
there are many stories and that we're
going to tell you about individual
stories of MPs some of whom are facing a
big surprise and a big shock at the
moment starting with Durham Northwest
Lord pickle some people thought she
might be the future Labour leader
it looks according to the exit poll as
if she might well loser see actually at
the moment it's a bit about too close to
call but it really is possible that she
could go given what we're seeing us
wearing given what we've seen in the
exit poll if she could fall to
conservative candidate Richard Holden
you can see him there I mean that would
be an enormous blow at one of the Rising
Stars of the Labour Party there Laura
pick core and you've also got other
potential monumental problems for the
party's stoke-on-trent North that's been
labor since nineteen fifty that looks
very vulnerable Wrexham labour since
1935 Lee since 1922 and is liberal
before that never conservative it could
well Cowan let's take a moment to talk
about the brexit party though because
we've talked a lot about the
Conservative Party talks a lot about the
Labour Party but what about the brexit
policy because the exit poll you'll
remember
suggest they won't win any seats that
their best chance was probably here in
Hartlepool so in Hartlepool Richard
theis was was facing
selection there one of the brexit
parties biggest hopes he might not win
but he might pick up a big share in the
constituency and the data suggests that
that seat is going to go from Labour
Hartlepool piece of metal to old sea
from labour to the Conservatives now
that would be extraordinary but it's so
interesting to see what's going on
beneath the surface is the brexit party
picking up votes off the Labour Party
but not necessarily off the Tory party
allowing the Tory party to get in there
that's the big question they're in see
tough to see the northeast we're seeing
that happen in the brexit party in some
cases that is allowing the Tories to do
well that's precisely precisely what
might well happen in other seats around
the country particularly Hartlepool seem
to have an implied Valley as well also
let's have a look at it down in the
metropolitan areas because this really
as Beth was saying a moment ago you know
Labour Party hoping to do well in those
metropolitan areas hoping to do well in
cities and indeed that's a big question
that they're facing in at the moment
Richmond Park might well ago to Sarah
only it looks at the moment like there
won't necessarily be as good news with
Boris Johnson there the Tory party
struggling in those urban areas doing
very well in towns instead Zac Goldsmith
could well lose his seat it was just 45
votes in 2017 so very close indeed but
the interesting thing is there are
diverse stories here the Tories doing
incredibly well in comparison to
previous elections in comparison to
history in the northeast but in other
seats around the country they may well
face losses but overall Dermot I mean as
you were saying a moment ago that exit
poll does look pretty convincing at the
moment given what we are seeing in these
results so far tonight well some of
those historical comparisons are pretty
breathtaking it thank you very much
indeed let's see if my next guest
Labour's shadow justice secretary
Richard Bergen think so how would you
very good evening to you mr. Burdon good
morning in actual fact how would you
describe the evening in the early
morning so far and what is to come
perhaps
well it's very disappointing and it's
very worrying I'm very disappointed very
worried about if this exit if the exit
poll proves to be accurate as it appears
like it is then I'm very worried about
all the children will wake up in poverty
all the people won't get paid a
ten-pound an hour minimum wage all the
people are homeless all the people who
won't get a council house all the people
stacked up with debts all of the people
are going to end up languishing on NHS
trolleys in our cuts of the bone
National Health Service I'm very very
disappointed and very worried about
their future seem I mean I'm here was a
brexit mr. Bergin but you know I'm
hearing this argument it's election
night the people have voted it's the
purest form of democracy it's still
fresh the votes are still being counted
in the majority of cases and you making
it sound like the people have made a
foolish choice haven't you been the ones
that have let them down if you believe
that you didn't make the case for it no
what's happened is we had a very similar
manifesto to the manifesto at the 2017
general election well with that
manifesto and with Jeremy's leadership
we gained 3 million votes the thing
which appears to be different this time
is it was an election in which bread's
it overshadowed traditional party
loyalties however I don't want to
prejudge I think we need to analyze
objectively where did we lose votes and
who to in what parts of the country and
the the totals and the proportions so we
need a sober serious analysis over the
next 24 hours or so okay well I can kind
of answer that where do you lose votes
just about everywhere who to just about
everyone are you beginning to believe
though with the results we have let's
deal with the hard and fast figures
Jenny Chapman sue Amon good colleagues
of yours gone are you beginning to think
is anybody safe in the labour party
tonight
well we don't take anything for granted
I don't take my seat for granted that's
why I've been working very hard on it we
need to look at the results that have
come out some deeply deeply
disappointing results some fantastic
colleagues losing their seats and as I
say I'm very worried about the future of
people in this country when they're
going to be allowed to buy a Thatcherite
like Boris Johnson what we've had
actually is the two sides of the coin of
establishments working together the
Thatcherite sin the brexit parts they
pretending the not gotcha rights and the
Thatcher rights in the Conservative
Party like Boris Johnson working
together it seems against labour and
against our progressive manifesto so of
course just as when we lost five million
votes between 1997 and 2010 when we
supported policies of austerity in war
we had to analyze those what we need to
do in the same way after what appears
like tonight results we need to analyze
very carefully those results and work
out what the Labour Party
I mean you've left something out on that
list of what you're going to analyze are
you gonna analyze Jeremy Corbyn in his
performance well of course Jeremy who I
admire greatly was raised by some voters
on the doorstep as ed Miliband and Tony
Blair and Gordon Brown were when I was
campaigning for them as well but and yes
some people did say things about Jeremy
that they'd read in the Daily Mail or
seen on the TV or seen in the Sun
newspaper of course
if these things didn't have traction
then these the Murdoch press and others
wouldn't bother spending the time
pushing it but actually the interesting
thing is that people on the doorstep
weren't complaining about our policies
and we wouldn't have had the policies
now the the last manifesto or this
manifesto if it weren't for Jeremy's
leadership and we gained three million
votes at the last general election is
very very disappointing tonight the only
difference it seems to me at this stage
but I want to analyze it further is the
fact that this was a brexit elect an
election the next election won't be a
brexit election and against a strong
fact Conservative Party we need to fight
back
not triangulate because the people who
will lose out in communities across the
country under five years of abortion
Johnson government deserve no less than
a fighting labor policy the one analyze
our bad results but won't give up okay
Richard Bergen thank you very much
indeed for joining us back to your back
to account therein leads to the shadow
justice secretary got sir South Britain
here Baroness Britain the presidents of
the Liberal Democrats a very good
evening to Vera Ness is it a good
evening it doesn't look like it for the
Lib Dems does it I think actually we
know that there are still six from the
exit poll they're still 65 seats are too
close to call and we know that a number
of those are ones where we are hotly in
contention and what's interesting about
tonight is that their seats that we've
not been particularly strong in before
so assure and Walton and Finchley in
Golders Green are just two examples of
that so I'm gonna wait to see what comes
in but you know well let's look at the
distance in terms of time between here
we are with the results coming in and
the beginning of the campaign you must
admit you've fallen from those mighty
soaring heights of imagining the job
Swenson might become prime minister now
you're talking like you normally talk as
live Dems which is picking up a few
seats here and there
I think the arithmetic changed when
Nigel Farage and Boris Johnson did the
deal to where they stood back in half
the seat that weather breaks apart I
stood back in half the seats and the
clearly that the poll starts to reflect
that what we have said over the last few
weeks is that we still remain determined
to stop brexit that we still remain
committed as it's very clear in our
manifesto that we wanted to people's
vote Joe was only talking about revoking
article 50 if she was prime minister
that's honest though again you know
against a pure slogan like get brexit
done
we were very our line was clear but it
often got cropped by other people you
just became the revoke party didn't you
a lot of people we front of our
manifesto talked about stock brexit and
the one thing we do know is tonight
we're seeing our votes share has gone up
not much but it's gone up and that's I
think we're gonna see it's gonna play
very well for us in the strong remain
seats where we know we are heavily in
contention so we we have all to play
and I was talking to Richard Bergen
there about leadership I mean are there
any questions about leadership if she
keep holds on to her seat jealous winks
and what else she might be in some
difficulty in eastern Barton well again
this one would you look at that would
that be on the list as far as we're
concerned the words that we've been
getting during the day in her seat are
things were looking good on streets and
she's absolutely only at the beginning
of her role as as leader and the party
likes what she's done in the message and
absolutely we're standing Foursquare
behind Joe just jump in if if she does
lose a seat then Davey will have to
become the leader won't he that's just
what will happen
look it's far too early to say anything
about us at all I don't want to get into
speculation and we will see what happens
but I think what is going to be
interesting is the seats that people
didn't expect us to get tonight that we
will get because of this issue about
strong remain votes and where we are
playing very strongly and by the way you
Joe switz and plays okay that the polls
for with Joe in those seats are strong
as well we'll wait and see but let's get
back to that point you made about to the
Conservatives and the brexit party
getting that their act together on the
leave side of the equation it didn't
happen well on the remain side did it
you've had a fairly confusing messages
it seems on the doorstep the Labour
Party the Lib Dems and Jos wins well I
think meant a lot of time criticizing
Jeremy Quartermaine if it was a brexit
election June you've got a more unified
message so the main problem is that
nobody quite knew where labour stood and
I think that point was aptly made by
Richard Bergen they are not a remain
party they have been arguing for a
people's vote and Jeremy Corbyn himself
has been arguing that what he wants as a
people's vote where he can put his
brexit plan that is not a real let me
ask you this actually look at all I mean
on that exit poll you know remain remain
is over
we're leaving would you be a rejoin
party you think further down the line I
think we always see benefit in us
[Music]
at the elation of another choice I'll
bring way we're getting a result of beta
bruh
there's the by-election a few months
back is as follows Briscoe Paul the
Conservative Party candidates 20 2009
[Applause]
further solute independent 264 Lisa Jane
labor party 19,000
[Applause]
bringing Michael Thomas brexit party
2105 its end of Martin John the official
monster raving loony party 113 Christian
People's Alliance 151 Democrats to stop
brick 6 2003 party 720 face Paul Bristow
is duly elected
[Applause]
there we have it so I've got the numbers
for you port Bristow he's making his
acceptance speech that again from Labour
by election they're the original Labour
MP I had to stand down a problem with
with the law and there was a by-election
and there we are let's just take through
the numbers I wonder worth hearing from
Paul Briscoe conservatives out there a
returning the by-election result and of
course the previous general election
result on which we base that the share
the changing chair of the vote progress
where they were 22,000 44 Lisa Forbes
who got in in the by-election 19,000 744
all the counties done and of course the
police making sure that this town was
free and fair amazing today but we
fought to the bitter end
and we've got the result that we deserve
and to the name many of my team
individually would take far too long but
I do want to thank my agent Peter my
campaign manager sandy and all of you
really know that you've done and finally
I want to mention my parents and Alan my
feet
bands we've stood with me through thick
and thin today is a massive day for me
but tomorrow could be an even bigger day
because it's what my second Charlie to
Sarah and my unborn child
but it's waiting
and yes because Petros rejected an
extreme and dangerous left-wing agenda
yeah we are just hearing our cutting
away from Peterborough there again
therefore the Conservative Party is also
hearing of it again seeing there for
yourself at the bottom of the screen
there conservatives gain the veil of
cleared from labour this is one of those
seats in the north-east of wales
so-called chris rellenas
John Bercow is helpfully adding there
the former MP now for the seat of the
Vale of cluded taken by the
Conservatives hard on the heels of
Peterborough returning to the
Conservatives let's talk to the Justice
Secretary mr. Buckland who's in Swindon
now there is with her the blue rosette
very prominent there it's standing proud
and presumably you are as well well I'm
still waiting for the declaration here
in south swing and the count is
proceeding apace I'm in the well-worn
phrase cautiously optimistic the result
in North Swindon from my colleague
Justin Tomlinson was a stunning 16,000
majority so we are very hopeful in what
is seen as a great bellwether of the
country that both Swindon seats will
stay blue tonight yeah I mean and it's
not just those isn't we've had
Peterborough Vale of cleared workings
and Darlington you mentioned that my
Valley that the lists is being added to
almost minute by minute right now and
that exit poll looks pretty on the
numbers for the Conservatives well I'm
very much hoping that it is and what I'm
really pleased to see is the
geographical spread of seats getting
James Davis back in the Vale occluded
Paul Bristow after many attempts winning
in Peterborough but those seats up in
Cumbria and in Northumberland and County
Durham this is a Conservative Party that
will represent the whole of the country
that will bring its challenges yes but
it will also bring huge opportunities
for the conservative and unionist party
well interesting what you say they want
to pick up on that to represent the
whole of the country
you know you understand of course I mean
I know you use that phrase but several
countries in the United Kingdom and let
me talk about Scotland just hearing we
mentioned the gains for the
Conservatives well the SNP have taken
Angus away from you and again on the
exit poll which you seem to accept the
direction of travel in Scotland the
direction of travel is that the SNP are
going to be very very well-meaning
presumably you're doing very badly what
do you think it means for the integrity
of the United Kingdom if the reserve
result turns out this way for the SNP I
very mindful of results in Scotland we
need to digest fully what the final
picture looks like what we must avoid is
more years of damaging and wasteful
debates about the Constitution you know
Scotland decided decisively to have
progressive devolution back in 1997 it
increased its powers ever since it's a
proud nation part of our United Kingdom
but I still believe passionately as a
Welshman and as a British patriot that
Scotland is better off with us we are
better together and I think that message
still has to be very clear from the
Conservative Party but at the same time
understanding the needs of the people of
Scotland respecting that I'm working as
construct only as possible to make sure
that the whole of United Kingdom Cleaves
together in a in a positive way ok
secretaries say thank you very much if
you were going to part knee let's see if
the Conservatives can hold on here or as
their main vote in London
dönitz let's listen in that the number
of votes recorded for each candidate at
the said election is as follows Fleur
Anderson Labour Party twenty two
thousand seven hundred and eighty
[Applause]
burger just Mackenzie green party 1133
will switch the Conservative Party
candid eighteen thousand
[Applause]
to which the Liberal Democrats don't
over to here that's to which the Liberal
Democrats 8,500
[Applause]
the total number of ballot papers
rejected as follows one two official
mark okay well they were going to get a
new and B anyway because Justine
greening who had held the seat stood
down left the party and was not standing
in partly but there you go not all doom
and gloom for the Labour Party again
there a big gain there am twenty two
thousand seven hundred and eighty four
the Labour candidate say around about
eighteen thousand for the Conservatives
and John Bercow so this is the mixed
picture picture isn't it in a strongly
remained seat and metropolitan remain
seat the Labour Party vote holding up
but in so many of the seats we haven't
seen too many declares somebody seeks in
their northeast in in Wales labour
losing them all together they consider
yes I mean we were doing the arithmetic
between ourselves Dermot you and I on
Beth earlier in the evening and it was
obvious that if the Conservatives would
have a majority that big of 86 it
remains to be seen but it's looking
likely well it meant that they were
going to have to make huge gains in the
north and the Midlands because we could
tell that they had lost seats in
Scotland and that was every prospect of
them losing seats in London Putney is
just different it is a very very very
heavily remain area just in greening was
the Member of Parliament there for 14
years and in my experience and
incredibly personal and highly regarded
parliamentarian in Westminster in all
likelihood she was very well regarded
locally and I don't know but it may be
that were some people locally who didn't
much like the way she was treated in
okay why he wear earring and Wales
though on the other way it's going that
Wrexham has gone to the Conservatives as
well and matching that exit over
Vaughn's that's the first time since
1935 and I mean this is so fascinating
because before we began the program the
Tories were telling me that they were
nervous and they said it looks like
we've had losses in London and will we
make them up by gains in the Midlands
and the north and look is what what is
happening and then there you have POC
they're turning to labor but also a
delicious little morsel is that in terms
of a big majority that was buried into
page four of the Conservative Party
briefing notes that they give out which
suggests that they didn't necessarily
think they were going to get such a big
majority if the exit poll is correct
ie they were probably predicated that
there would be a smaller majority
conservative majority than they thought
they would get so this is much more than
they hoped for which suggests that the
red wall as I said well it has come down
in a way that it didn't and that's
exactly what Ed Conway is going to talk
to us about just the scale of these
inroads ed that the Conservatives are
making into these labour territories
that's right but I mean let's let's
start with that last result partly
because I mean you know here we have it
on our board which was looking at some
of the marginal labour Tory targets so
those are the seats that Labour wanted
to win most of them the Conservative
Party
there's Putney over there touken up to
2% swing to win it and there are the
conservative talk isn't just to look at
that to take a close this board you
might thought oh maybe it's not going
quite so badly for the Labour Party but
let's have a look a little bit a little
a little bit deeper into that labour red
ward so these seats that they were
defending that they thought they might
have enough strength to defend the
Tories off on this is the the red wall
and this is the Labour defense and these
are the kinds of seats many of them in
the Northeast
here's Workington in the northwest that
they expected that they might be able to
hold on to because these are very
traditional labour seats up to a four
percent swing would have lost them these
seas it's more than 4% it's up to a six
percent swing would have lost them
working too much with a percent swing
would have lost them B's C's truely
obviously the speaker's seat they've
they felled on up to a 10 percent swing
would have lost them Blythe ally
Anderson indeed precisely what's
happened we're seeing 10 percent swings
from the Labour Party to the
Conservative Party of course much of the
Northeast not all those seats are going
but I mean these are enormous enormous
swings by the grand scheme of things and
when you have a look at seats for
instance like Workington like Darlington
let's just kind of zoom into the details
of these seeds so let's I'll change the
screen and we can have a look at what's
going on Ben
the surface so we're talking about kind
of ten percentage swings in both of
these seats working in Darlington both
conservative gains from the Labor Party
have a look at some of these numbers so
brexit leave votes so that in the
referendum in 2016 about sixty percent
voted leave in Workington over here in
Darlington about 58 percent very similar
story there under 45 how old are these
constituencies they are slightly older
than the average so the average across
the UK is they're slightly older than
the average graduates and this is rather
interesting one quite low in terms of
the average number of people who are
graduates and let's just kind of think
about that so graduates look at this map
here we have Workington over there let's
take that map and plot all of these
constituencies so these are
constituencies in the UK against their
percentage of graduate voters because
we'll get a sensitive where the Tory
party are starting to pick up seats
let's move those across here onto our
chart now the further you go here the
more the higher their percentage of
graduates so this is a measure of higher
education and the interesting thing is
the Tories are starting to pick up seats
here around this kind of area of the
chart you've got Workington in there
around there where they have on average
lower levels of graduates in the
population that's a very different kind
of distribution what we've seen in the
past so this is an interesting way in
which the map is changing now the vast
majority as you've seen if these seats
are gray at the moment have yet to
declare but as the night goes on as the
morning goes on we'll see just what the
color what this map is looking like and
we'll also plot agates other things as
well just before before I go Toma and
shout at me if anything's about says
class but seats in which the Lib Dems
have lost their deposit let's just have
a look at that should we compare that
the number of seats where the Lib Dems
have lost their deposits so far and
compare it to the brexit party so far
we're early in the night but so far the
Lib Dems have lost their deposit in all
of these seats embezzled and Southdown
developed curd in Wrexham it's 12 so far
12 seats that the Lib Dems have lost
their deposit thus far
how many have the brexit party lost now
they're not fighting all of the same
seats so bear that in mind but it's 10
and their bridge support he's doing
actually a little bit better than many
people had expected beneath the surface
as we were saying earlier actually
having an impact on the final result not
necessarily winning any of those seats
the export
just they might not but things are going
on beneath the surface that suggests
they are doing a little bit better than
all the people that had things going on
right now I'm gonna cut you off Furyk is
declaring got another one coming in here
we go throated leave and a declaration
imminence we'll wait for them to beam
the speak because certain other dramatic
things have happened and they are
reading it out recorded for each
candidate at the said election is as
follows
Doyle price Jacqueline the Conservative
Party candidate twenty-seven thousand
seven hundred and ninety five votes
[Applause]
Harvey been the Green Party 807 Kent
John George Labour Party sixteen
thousand three hundred and thirteen
stone Stewart Malcolm Liberal Democrats
1510 well there we have it it was a
conservative seat it's staying a
conservative seat and some Jackie Doyle
price return there with a very much
increased majority was or the election
happened seen as something perhaps of a
labor target John Kent they're only
getting 16,000 Jackie doll price
reelected air with the majority of
eleven thousand four hundred eighty-two
coming in much more quickly now stop
them north
[Applause]
Liberal Democrat 1631 Martin undream
breakfast party 3907
it was as follows want of an official
market zero voting for more than one
candidate 26 right thing mark I went to
the voter could be identified two
unmarked avoid for uncertainty ok Vale
of Glamorgan a conservative seat Allen
Ken's was the and be there let's listen
in we got a declaration under wife died
yes all I from organic and that can
verdict of Ansem or blade leash I are
avoid Ebola invasive Fellig online
Cairns Alan the Conservative Party
candidate twenty seven thousand three
hundred and five
Divac sized meal tree hunter fin love
look Edwards Belinda Welsh Labour severe
Camry twenty three thousand seven
hundred and forty three Divac tree mail
scythe can't petrol sick tree slaughter
Anthony David the Green Party plight
where 3,250 One Tree meal I found him
digging Williams Lawrence Vlad Vlad 508
pimp cancer growth therefore I give
public notice that Alan Kearns is duly
elected as the member of okay Alan kids
getting back in there in Vale of
Glamorgan slightly increased majority
they're up to three thousand five
hundred sixty two again another above
for the Labour Party mites before that
exit poll came out being seen as one of
the potential targets for labor butter
Labor's vote more or less staying on the
numbers who was an increased turnout
they would put out than have put up the
number of voters say labor more or less
standing still the Conservatives gaining
two point three percent the Green Party
up five and a bit percent plied the Lib
Dems and others down I'm told we are
expecting a result fairly soon staying
in Wales included south we've seen Vale
of cleric change
to its South a Labour majority there
around about 4,300 but while we wait for
more results to get in time I think just
to check in with a deputy political
editor Sam Coates is feeding it all in
where we got Putney there again for the
Labour Party but apart from that it's a
pretty grim night Dermot that's right I
want to draw your attention to one
result that we've had in the last 10
minutes or so and that is of Lee in
Greater Manchester it's the seat that
Andy Burnham used to hold before he
became mayor of Manchester Greater
Manchester that had turned conservative
on a massive swing if you look at the
list of targets for the Conservative
Party that they wanted to take from
labor that was 91 on their list
it truly does suggest a dire evening for
the Conservatives now a few minutes ago
you saw from Edie Edie Conway on his
wall how the red wall for labour was
tumbling some of the seats that people
really didn't think at the start of this
campaign would fool have now gone blue
Lee is the furthest along that list of
any of them but I think the point that
Labour folk tonight are just coming to
terms with is that these these seats
haven't been taken by tiny majorities
they've been taken by really rather big
majorities so Wrexham 2,000 votes
they'll have cleared 1,800 lead nearly
2,000 votes Workington 4,000 votes now
the point about that is that it's gonna
take not just one election but maybe two
or three general elections for the
Labour Party to know that they can get
places like that back we've got shadow
cabinet ministers we've got the first
one sue Heyman went in Workington but on
the watch list we've got Laura peacock
in Durham North West and in cote leslie
led the shadow scottish secretary I
think the bloodbath is starting to dawn
on labour figures that's why I'm being
urged to mention that already figures
like Lisa Nandi are under pressure to
stand for the leadership if there's a
vacancy anytime soon okay Sam thank you
very much indeed may have missed our
attention some results from Northern
Ireland have been coming in the Alliance
Party a seat for them
gained from the independent Silvie
Hermann stood down there but in north
down taking their DUP had hopes of that
but the alliance party getting in there
up against two unionist party LC Eunice
body and the Democratic Unity Party Shin
FINA for held on in Tyrone West want to
talk now to the leader of the brexit
party Nigel Faraj well Nigel Farage I
mean it's clear that in Boris Johnson's
terms brexit is going to get done if
this exit poll is to be believed and it
looks like it is to be you happy about
that well look the last thing I wanted
was a second referendum that would have
been absolutely dreadful for the country
and that was the main reason why I said
we should stand down in those 317 seats
because they were in areas like the
South of England the southwest of
England the Liberal Democrats would have
won lots of them and they themselves now
say that it rather pollaxe their
campaign so of course I'd prefer Boris
Johnson to be Prime Minister talking in
positive terms about brexit the slight
problem of course is that getting brexit
done isn't really true because if we
pass the withdrawal agreement as it is
unamended that I fear we're in for
perhaps up to three years of agonizing
negotiations don't you believe in then
Boris Johnson when he says you know this
11 months of transition and whatever
happens by the end of 2020 it's out you
know you don't believe in me think would
go for an extension well even if he goes
into this with the best of intentions
the problem with the withdrawal
agreement is that it puts so much power
into mr. Barney as hands and I I would
have thought they would enjoy seeing our
discomfort look I hope I'm wrong I hope
we finish up with a free trade deal I
hope we don't finish up with regulatory
alignment on everything from financial
services to fisheries but as it is the
way that withdrawal agreement is worded
is from a brexit ears point of view not
satisfactory you know what you agree on
one thing anyway with my guess I'm sure
you've been watching during the evening
former Speaker John Burke oh and that is
John burka on the fact mr. Faraj they're
saying that passing that withdrawal
agreement is not getting brexit done
well we agree on that point but for
pretty different reasons as I note the
expression on Nigel's face shows he's
relieved to discover my position is to
say that they can get the withdrawal
agreement through but there's a huge
amount more to be done if breakfast is
to become a reality and that will take
several years I think to be fair Nigel's
point is that he just very strongly
disapproves of the withdrawal agreement
because I'm he could articulate it for
himself he doesn't think it constitutes
a proper withdrawal that I think that's
obviously where you begin to differ
I mean I'm always happy to be obliging
Nigel and to try to advance your own
argue
absolute Copperbottom
rubbish nevertheless I'm happy to help
to articulate your point of view if I'm
invited to do say what is not common
bottom rubbish is that people act me a
campaign for a quarter of a century for
us to become an independent country and
my concern is we're leaving one set of
EU treaties for a new set of EU treaties
which bind us too closely and I want us
to be absolutely free but look that
argument is one that will begin next
week for now for tonight I did all that
I could leading a very new party that
was set up to get brexit back on track I
tried to use whatever influence I could
to stop a second referendum and I think
I've had some success let me put another
point - well I'll let John Bercow put it
as well another point that John Burke
has been made about the size of the
majority which is forming here
potentially and if it is on the exit
poll of 86 seats John Buckley put it -
Nigel Frost that it it frees Boris
Johnson to do more or less whatever he
wants yeah I'm sure the point will have
occurred to Nigel Boris Johnson can
pivot either way on the back of a very
large majority he can either take the
attitude I'm going to go ahead I'm going
to insist on what I've said so far no
extension to the transition period that
will be an agreement on trade and we'll
be out by the end of 2020 and that way
he would be holding too firm to what
he's been saying over a period of months
and that will probably strike Nigel as
more
less satisfactory alternatively he could
say I've got a big majority it's gonna
take longer I don't care what I said in
the past what is what I'm saying now or
I don't get a change tack and that a
cake will bring a scowl from Miss I mean
I mean look that is a very very good
point to make the truth of it is that
half the cabinet voted remain Michael
Gove I was with him earlier clearly
wants the softest of Albrecht's it's
Boris whilst he's committed to leave as
never really I don't think being keen on
leaving on WTO terms and my view is a
big majority means that the influence of
the ERG the influence of those who are
committed Euroskeptics becomes a lot
weaker and I would expect I'll predict
that by the 1st of July we will be
extending the transition period out till
2022 well I hate to say so Nigel and I'm
sure it's embarrassing for you too but I
think we might agree about that so let
me let me put another point - you have
given the performance of the brexit
party and the seats you've stood in
against those some Labour MPs doing
fairly well tended to join the Green
Party the Lib Dems and others who are
coming on this programme saying we
urgently need electoral reform doesn't
allow you're gonna get any seats oh look
you know I let you Kip in 2015 we stood
across the whole country we got 4
million votes and one seat that needs to
change I do believe that I think the
postal voting system is so open to fraud
and intimidation that needs to change I
think the House of Lords the ability of
governments these days to use you know
patronage in terms of peerages is
outrageous outdated and rather than that
needs to change and I also think you
know we're gonna need a written
constitution because we now have a
Supreme Court making political decisions
without any rulebook to work from so
look I'm a radical I think British
politics is living with a set of
nineteenth-century institutions that
need to be brought into the 21st century
the problem is it doesn't suit a
conservative party with a big majority
to do
of those now you let me tease you you
spoke with seamless and undiluted
eloquence in opposition to the use of
patronage and you reference the House of
Lords therefore I think we can take it
from you at 212 in the morning that if
you are offered a peerage you will in
fact turn it down as a matter of
absolute and unbending Ferrari and
principle well that's the difference
John isn't it they won't even offer you
one they had they keep trying to fire
big over sale agreement and Joe Burke oh
listen results son coming in and
expected not Virology be interested hear
that Hartlepool is expected to declare
soon richard toys your your Chairman's
standing there see if you actually might
manage to get a seat the exit poll
doesn't seem to suggest that and thank
you very much any we're going to say
goodbye to mr. Viraj Stockton South this
was labor gain in 2017 a declaration
expected they're cleared South you may
remember me mentioning a few minutes
earlier in Wales up in the northeast of
Wales there we didn't show you the
numbers though again they're from the
Labour Party Simon Baynes there with
sixteen thousand two hundred and twenty
two labourer pushed back to nearly
15,000 Hartlepool I just mentioned well
let's see how this one goes Brett Syd
party there may be the Conservatives
will do well as well let's see how it
goes
we're going to bring in that shot in a
moment or two in between time there we
are
declaration imminent as I said that once
the seat of Peter Mandelson way back
when in those distances where our ears
Mike Hill that defending now for labour
in this constituency the results for a
general election are declared by the
first citizen of the
which is the ceremonial mayor of
Hartlepool Borough Council Council the
mayor Brenda loins and I would like to
invite Brenda live loins now to declare
the results of this election Thank You
Jill
aye Brenda loins being the returning
officer for the election of a member of
parliament for the Hartlepool
constituency held on the 12th of
December 2019 to hereby give notice that
the number of arts require recorded for
each candidate at the said election is
as follows bousfield Joseph Alexander
commonly known as bousfield Joe
independent 911 votes
from a Kevin socialist Labor Party 494
volts Hagin Andrew Michael commonly
known as Hagin and a Liberal Democrats
1,696 sports hill michael roberts
commonly known as might as hell Mike
Labor Party fifteen thousand four
hundred and sixty four votes Parton
Stefan Richard the Conservative Party
candidate eleven thousand eight hundred
and sixty nine votes
Tice Richard brexit party ten thousand
six hundred and three votes the number
of ballot papers rejected was as follows
wanted of an official mark nil voting
for more candidates than thought it was
entitled to twenty seven writing amok
well there we are a dramatic result in
Hartlepool in spite of the fact that
it's going down on the school board as a
labor hold Mike Hill they're elected
with the reduced majority 3595 but the
tale of that seed even go back to the
numbers is that the split in the vote
between the conservative candidates
honor around that twelve thousand and
the brexit party around about ten
thousand and this the argument remember
you keep were second they're not so very
long ago if you put those two numbers
together you actually get a leave
majority there perhaps Mike Hill as sir
dodged a bullet there so to speak John
Bercow nodding along right now I'm told
we are hearing well I was just saying
that Hartlepool was where Nigel fraud
made the announcement that he was going
to stand down in 308 conservative seats
and that was their main target really
Hartlepool but as you can see there's be
a 25% increase Blackpool South declaring
right now
Conservative Party candidate 16,000 247
Brown David Brett sick party 2009
Coleman Gary Ian independent 368 Daniels
Rebecca Irene commonly known as Becky
Green Party 563 Green Willie me Lewis
commonly known as bill Liberal Democrats
1008 Marsden
Gordon Labour Party 12,000 557 and
another win for the Conservatives in a
heavily leave voting seat back in 2016
Scott Benson they're getting in and a
very decent majority taking it from the
Labour Party majority 3690 labour Gordon
Marston had a majority in 2017 2523 so
another big turnover there in the north
northwest this time in a leave leaning
seat Stella Creasy we are hearing the
Labour MP down to London in Walthamstow
is waiting for her result and there she
is there with a a big rosette oh I'm
working out there Stella Creasy you got
the little one act tonight sleep or
awake there well she started heckling me
when I gave my acceptance speech so
she's starting to wake up a little bit
but she's two weeks old so I can really
leave her at home okay well I indeed and
tell us though about about the night's
personal results aside well tell us
about that first of all because there is
a tale of two elections at the very
least isn't there developing for the
Labour Party yeah look I'm extremely
honored that the people of Walthamstow
have yes again voted for me to be their
MP and acutely conscious they don't just
need a Labour MP they need a Labour
government and I can't pretend that what
is happening across the rest of the
country isn't absolutely devastating and
I'm gutted to see very very good
colleagues who I know just like me are
passionate about
local communities passionate about this
country not being returned to Parliament
I am very concerned about what Boris
Johnson could do especially if he gets
the the majority people are talking
about and very aware that we've had 10
years of austerity bleeding dry
communities like this we're now possibly
facing a very hard brexit and that
raises some really tough questions for
people like me in the labor movement
which I've been part of for over 27
years now about why we weren't able to
win the trust of the British public at
this point in time to offer them an
alternative and is this inquest gonna
focus on that you mentioned the message
but what about the medium through the
forum at the top of the leader the
questions need to be asked about Jeremy
Corbyn I'm sure there will be questions
asked about all sorts of things yes
including leadership also including
policies including campaigning that's
what happens after an election right now
it's about half-past one close to 2:00
in the morning we're still seeing what
is happening obviously some of my
colleagues are managing to hold on which
is fantastic some of them aren't winning
and I'm really hoping we're gonna get a
positive result here tonight in
Chingford that's the one result we're
waiting for now here look we have to see
how the pieces lie first but I don't
think any of us can pretend this is what
we were hoping for and what we've been
fighting for and obviously we owe it to
the British public to ask ourselves why
we didn't win
you mentioned Chingford they're waiting
to see if Ian Duncan Smith might be
might be removed by by a remain vote and
that's what I refer to I suppose in my
first question to you this tale of two
elections at least is labour now
becoming a Metropolitan Party you can
only win in remaining seats like yours
let's see how the results fold out from
what I understand we've just won held on
and in Hartlepool which I think you
would argue is a very different type of
seat we have to see what the results are
I've only seen a handful come in so far
observe in here at the count and also
looking after this one but I do accept
the challenge that we need to be a party
that can win support across this country
in order to win a government I don't
think that's an unfair question I just
don't know at this point in time what
the test is that we've met
okay thank you very much indeed we are
hearing from the leader Jeremy Corbyn
thank you very much for coming well
Jeremy Corbyn arriving a discount
therein is Islington in North London
we'll see how he's done when they
declare their round of applause from the
party activists some shots there from
some of the journalists in there about
asking him if he was going to resign no
answer specifically on that issue from
Jeremy Corbyn and as I say some cheering
not too much of it from the party
activists and I want to talk now too
they was just Phillips sir a Labour
candidate one of the Labour candidates
in Birmingham and just Phillips
let's stay because we're looking at
pictures of your leader would you be
cheering him would you be clapping him
if you were there this evening I might
act with courtesy so yes maybe I don't
think that it's nothing to gloat about
is there that I don't think that I don't
think that there's much for the Labour
Party to feel particularly good about
and to be chopping and clapping and
cheering but you know what these things
are like it's for the cameras isn't it
well out of courtesy I mean do you think
that okay after a period of reflection
and examination you need a new leader
I mean it would be impossible to say
honest anything other than that but you
as I've said on everybody use put a
camera in front of my face I'm not going
to stand here and scalp Jeremy Corbyn
the country once all the results are in
it appears it is making quite a clear
statement about how it feels about the
Labour Party the Labour Party's offer
the Labour Party for quite some time and
you know I'm not I'm not going to be the
person who writes your headlines because
actually I think that there are other
people I'm just a mere backbencher there
are other people who probably aren't
letting you put cameras in front of
their faces who probably should be
talking about what they think has gone
wrong and I'm not going to write your
headlines to you tonight okay we don't
you've got a change you're right we
don't know what the headlines are fully
going to be yet but so the results are
coming in in line with what the exit
poll is telling us and many people like
you prominent figures in the Labour
Party are saying yeah well it's not
going to be a good evening to to say the
least so just let me ask you it's
terrible well there we are a bit of a
headline in itself one might say Jess
Phillips but this issue of where labour
can win it's it's the cities now you're
looking like you could become almost an
extinct species in in the towns and
major parts of the kind of
post-industrial northeast northwest
Wales the list goes on it won't become
extinct if we properly go out and listen
to what is going wrong and properly act
on it and actually try and do something
it's funny because Jeremy Corbyn is
always being seen as being of radical
something radically different but the
reality is is the Labour Party needs to
radically change because I don't believe
it's extinct in towns or in places where
I am absolutely certain as somebody who
represents a leave seat that has
suffered terribly from austerity
the Conservative Party will be found
incredibly wanting and so I don't think
that the Labour Party is extinct and I
think it has every chance to rebuild
itself
but in that notwithstanding tonight is
terrible it's horrendous it's
heartbreaking it's painful it's painful
for the people that I need to serve it's
painful for all of my constituents who
are facing real challenges because of
decisions made by the people who have
governed us for nearly a decade
I remember when things used to get
better and now people have just got used
to things getting worse okay and that is
a tragedy that tonight the Labour Party
wasn't able to rescue them from that
okay Jess Phillips thanks very much
indeed for spending the time to talk to
us so we want to go live now to this
count of Labour leader Jeremy Corbyn
there in North London my colleague
Sophie Ridge is there and Sophie we saw
this ripple of applause as he arrived
looks fairly muted tell us about it I
think it does feel quite muted here I
mean this is really is you know Jeremy
Corbyn stomping ground he's held this
heat this seat since 1983 he's certainly
not under pressure here if the number of
red papers been counted up for anything
to go by but certainly when he came in
although he was greeted by supporters by
colleagues there was a ripple of
applause it does feel muted and that is
clearly because of the exit poll and the
results coming in so far he may not be
under pressure here in Islington North
but he is certainly under pressure
nationally and I think there'll be
questions asked of his leadership as the
night unfolds because 71 seats lot
losses that the exit poll is predicting
the worst results for many decades we've
seen some of these results coming out
soon one of the results that we're
expecting to hear right now is in
Stockton South again this is the kind of
libo ting area where labour has been
under pressure so we can have a court
listen to try and find out what's
happening there
a special drug that the number of votes
recorded for each candidate is as
follows deadly Brendon Michael William
Liberal Democrat 2338
[Applause]
okay we need to leave that go to
Chingford Ian Duncan Smith a target for
the remain as pfizer Shaheen Labour
Party 22200 thank you either therefore I
give public notice that Ian Duncan Smith
is to be elected as the Member of
Parliament for Chingford a Woodford
Green constituency
we know back that one of the top targets
there for labor and the remaining Klein
vote form a leader of the Conservative
Party of course leading leading leave a
brackety a member of the European
research group well he's back and what
did I see him breathing almost a sigh of
relief they will get you the the numbers
specifically on that constituency very
soon but just there at the bottom of
your screen
well conservatives have reached 50 seats
of this predicted total 368 a bit of a
swing there to labor and the Lib Dem
vote though look at that just about
splitting it enough to let Ian Duncan
Smith in it was a close-run thing let's
listen in to mr. Duncan Smith can I can
I thank I hope on everyone's behalf mr.
mayor the returning officers all those
who have worked incredibly hard here
both at the the polling stations and
also here doing the count tonight can I
thank all of them the police and all the
security staff and everybody else I
wonder if we could give them a round of
applause they've done incredibly well
[Applause]
I'd personally like to thank my wife
Betsy who's been with me through thick
and thin
through all these years and also the
incredible team my team who have worked
unbelievably hard to get the results oh
my thanks go to all of you heartfelt
thanks for the hard work that you've all
put in can I
[Applause]
and can I most of all thank after 27
years my constituency Ching from the
woodford green I think they are
fantastic and I dedicate the next five
years to serving them in my best
capacity that I possibly can no matter
what they voted no matter what their
views are I'm pleased therefore
incredibly grateful to them that they
have returned me once more to represent
this constituency and I'm also
incredibly pleased that it looks like
that I shall be doing so starting from
Monday in a conservative majority
government thank you very much indeed in
Duncan Smith back in their narrow squeak
inching for let's say go to a Labour
gain from last time around practices
2019 do hereby give notice that a number
of votes recorded for each candidate at
the third election is as follows
Kim caddy the Conservative Party
candidate twenty one thousand six
hundred and twenty two Lois Lane Davis
Green Party 1529
[Applause]
Marsha untold occurred over Labor Party
27,000 to
[Applause]
what he can heal yourself raucous
cheering thereby a and the relief labour
supporters Marsha did Cordova who took
the seat in 2017 an increased majority
there in a heavily remain voting seats
their return we haven't got the numbers
for you but there we are they are back
and they've also reached 50 seats also
got to alert you to another of the big
turnouts a big turn ups from 2017
Canterbury you may remember when that
was declared that Labour had gained that
with a very slim majority of 187 we are
hearing that rosy Duffield yes John
Burke Oh rosy Duffield
has got back in there the exit polls
suggesting that the Tories might regain
Canterbury well they haven't again and
look at the turnout 75% again a remain
leaning she knows he does feel there
29,000 over there conservatives 27,000
rows he Duffield elected with an
increased majority as it was only 187
well she's multiplied that by more or
less exactly 10 1836 let's go back to
Sophie Ridge and get her assessment of
what we're what we're seeing here Sophie
is in all of us pudding in part two -
Jess Phillips labour where they are
doing well tend to be these cities with
remain leaning seats and in the
southeast and these farce ways it looks
like of their former heartlands under
real threat it really does feel Dermot
like we're seeing a realignment and that
is certainly what people in labour are
saying as well and labour candidates at
the elections saying that they think
there's different stories going on in
London and in the rest of the country
talking to people in close to Jeremy
Corbyn the Labour leader as well they're
saying and she was to sort of just
hearing some overhead speakers from the
the declarations here not we're not
expecting them quite yet though people
close to Jamie Corbett also saying and
that just look at the areas where we're
losing that goes to the heart of the
problem and I think it's brexit but also
perhaps go a bit further about identity
as well and do they feel that the Labour
Party really represents the identity
that they feel and politically as
opposed to being perhaps a bit too much
of a liberal metropolitan a party that
some feel it's becoming and certain
you're seeing that in some of the seats
labour taking games in places like
Putney losing some of those really
long-standing seats they've had for a
long time the life value Workington
Blackpool south Darlington and we can
bring in my colleague Jason peril now
who's been following a Jeremy Corbyn
you're just looking at pictures there of
him arriving at the counts just a short
time ago [ __ ] 10 minutes ago wasn't it
Jason and you were there what did he
look like
well I just got him getting out in the
car actually so when he was still
outside and he was quite hard to get in
I asked him you know his reaction for
result he just thanked me for the
question but did not sir
asked him if he was gonna stand down he
was quite determined to get to the door
asked him a few times he didn't answer
earlier when I spoke to someone from his
camp who was with him at the time of him
get seeing the exit results he was
apparently in shock he that person said
he needed a bit of time to just absorb
the result but I think as his colleagues
absorb it especially those more in the
centre of the party are they're reacting
and blaming him and he must be seeing
that he must be seeing some of his own
MP is really turning on him now
especially those who tried to oust him
back in 2016
saying a sense of i-told-you-so
also a lot of people MPs I've spoken to
in the North saying that he's created a
cabinet that was to London centric and
saying you know don't just blame this on
brexit it's about more than that yeah
okay thank you Jason very much all about
analysis well as Jason was just saying
pressure really growing on Jeremy Corbyn
many feel that he should be considering
his position if that exit poll is right
if the losses that they've seen food far
had continued throughout the night
projected to lose at 71 seats compared
to in 2017 so certainly pressure growing
out on the Labour leadership now and
actually for now okay yeah
Sofia back with you soon I just want to
talk to John Burke about some of those
results we've just seen first of all the
labor holding and increasing their
majority in Canterbury holding on we're
seeing there as well in Norwich South
again what so V was saying really these
these remains seats labour holding on
there but not in a lot of other places
no so if you region of course it's
absolutely right about that Dermot but I
think that's just one other point to add
in relation to rosy duffel boosting her
majority in Canterbury and Clive Lewis
being returned in north/south and that
is that it's not just a matter of remain
Perseids is that those two particular
constituencies are of course university
constituencies a very significant
student vote there as far as Battersea
is concerned happens to be my home seat
Marshall de Cordoba has strengthened her
position there and that doesn't really
come as a surprise the demographic is
just markedly different from that in 70s
reflect on and your overall thoughts as
well Barry political editor there in
Chingford and Duncan Smith getting back
in a feature there of the III called it
the remain vote let's call it the
referendum vote but labour in the Lib
Dems well if one of them understood they
had enough to do this was meant to be
one of the chant ACTA can tell you they
were very very worried about that
Priti Patel the home suck she was in
that constituency
leafleting with the in Duncan Smith he
has worked his socks off and he's only
just hung on but keep talking but I'm
gonna throw this in there conservatives
have gained Scunthorpe we now have the
numbers yet but they're they they
they've just keep come yet I mean look
this is really a seismic election
election here we've become used in
certainly my sort of lifetime of
covering politics narrow majorities
coalition governments hung Parliament's
Parliament's and party systems
that's give-and-take and compromise this
sort of majority is going to give Boris
Johnson the kind of power executive
power to really potentially reshape our
country to have a very different type of
politics for the next five years I can't
overstate what a big change this is
going to be for the country and secondly
and thus Kanthal result reflects it the
basis of the parties are changing London
is becoming Metropolitan University
educated liberal if you like the Tories
are taking traditional labor
working-class Heartland areas and that
is going to have an effect too on how
Boris Johnson has to run his government
because he's going to have a different
bunch of voters now just just very
quickly John because make your point
sure know what we've got here is
identity politics trumping old-fashioned
socioeconomic determination of how
people vote people used to vote on a
straightforward economic basis and maybe
people are now betting on a different
basis and the question is will that be
sustained
we've got was 22 years and has not been
a Conservative member of parliament
force come thought until now yeah lots
of implications both major parties there
another gay look like just keep coming
as I say red car 15 points swing or so
again for the Conservatives 15-point
swing or so away from the Labour Party
there's the numbers for you what reading
that makes for Jeremy Corbyn and all the
leadership of Labor Party Jacob young in
there at 18 thousand eight hundred and
eleven and look at that change in share
it's just the way it's just the way that
the Labour vote has been whacked down 18
percent for their brexit party doing
fairly well there prexy party standing
in these in these former labour seats
now a red car again another gain listen
the Conservatives also doing well in
Wales we've seen held on in Vale of
Glamorgan took Wrexham took clued south
and Dan Whitehead is there to talk about
there the picture in Wales Dan
yeah Derman were fascinating evening we
are having here in Wales vale of
glamorgan
Alan Ken's the Conservative MP holding
on to his seat here despite
controversies he had to stand down of
course as the Welsh secretary at the
start of November but he held down at
this seat here doubled his majority in
fact to 4,000 votes but we are seeing
some significant Tory gains in Wales and
to discuss those we are joined by the
head of politics from Cardiff University
Roger Allen Scully thank you for joining
us Roger and I mean let's start with
Wrexham for instance what have we seen
up there tonight all the Conservatives
not had this seat for a very very long
time they did not win it at all in the
entire 20th century yeah they won the
seat quite clearly tonight and that was
very significant actually result because
it's the first ever time that the Welsh
conservatives are elected a female MP
significant polling earlier this week it
looks like that the Tory gains that you
had predicted going that way what else
have we seen especially in North Wales
well we're seeing you know labour
potentially on labour being the dominant
party in Wales almost a century yeah
they could come very close to if not
actually being wiped out in North Wales
losing all of their seats there we're
seeing also significant losses in terms
of labour vote share and some seats in
South Wales maybe one or two further
seats going to the Conservatives and it
seems as if the Welsh conservatives
could equal Margaret Thatcher's record
from 1983 of 14 Welsh Conservative MPs
you know the best they've done in any
election since the war and that's the
record anything above 14 for the Tories
in Wales is going to be a record yeah
absolutely this would be genuinely
historic and you know seeing the results
here seeing the results in other parts
of Wales it's far from inconceivable
when this night is done they could
actually do that what's going on here
Roger
is this brexit is it Jeremy Corbyn is it
both we're seeing I think in many parts
of Wales as we've seen in much of
England as well in those sort of smaller
towns and some of those traditional
labour areas that voted for brexit
people are deserting the Labour Party in
significant numbers going straight over
to the Conservatives in the ultimate
labour nightmare we're also seeing
though I think you know the Jeremy
Corbyn leadership did not work in Wales
Labour's traditional Bastion anymore
that's worked in many of Labour's other
traditional
a strength we're just gonna cross to
Anglesey I think I believe we're gave me
a declaration there now okay well thanks
Dan and talking about to Wales there and
the threat to Labour's dominance there
are so many decades and indeed centuries
but so we were looking at the picture in
in ishbal and this of course is a Labour
seat that on current performance is
under threat so we're not able to bring
you that declaration bringing the
numbers yeah but what I do want to tell
you about is that the s end be made
again it's not all great news for the
Conservatives and certainly not in in
Scotland the SNP have taken aqil and
South Perth sure John Nichol is is back
there John Nicholson yes excuse me John
Nicholson is it is back there after a
short period out after losing the seat
in 2017 john byrne no no no no
previously the Member of Parliament that
constituency was the indefatigable
mustard airbrushed osmeña nobody could
ever history she had a registering was
record but she lost her seat no John
Nicholson was a member yes where and now
he's got back in this constituency
that's obviously very good news for you
but the overall point being Beth Rigby
that yes
Oh overall a great victory it looks like
for for the Conservatives but not in
Scotland and you know not in parts of
the remaini South and the remaining and
some of the cities so and if one theme
of the election it seems to be will be
this return to big majority government
if this plays out as it looks I mean
that's going to be fascinating in terms
of how our politics works but in terms
of the Conservative Party if they have
losses in Scotland if the SNP really
build their base that will just
strengthen Nicholas sturgeons hand in
calling for second independence
referendum you put into the mix brexit
which Scotland voted against and what
you can see is a strong Boris Johnson in
Westminster in in Parliament there the
west wrongs with Wes
can labor hold on here majority 4,400
from the last election said election is
as follows
Bailey Sean Steven the Conservative
Party candidate 1701 17,000 the biggie
pardons 17 talukas Helen flora commonly
known as Lucas flow Liberal Democrats to
stop rx-8 915 Cunningham James Thomas
Labor Party
13600 and $20 EO Valerio Francesco to
gains in quick succession for their
conservatives once again west bromwich
west their that we're looking at inish
mom that we briefly focused on their
angle seat in wales again there from the
Labour Party looking at West Bromwich
West as I say there was a majority there
for the Labour Party of 4400 it was a
seat the verbage 68.7% to leave the
European Union the brexit party standing
there not doing too well and this
conservative gain from labour they've
turned that 4,000 odd majority for
labour into a majority for the
Conservatives of 3,700 or so taking just
over 50% of the votes and the Labour
Party cooked below 40% and changing
share up 10% nearly 11 percent the
Conservatives the Labour vote down 12
and a half percent brexit party 5.3
percent Bishop Auckland very slim
majority from the bar selection for
labour parishioners also Paul Durham
County election of a member of
parliament for Bishop Auckland held on
Thursday of the 12th of December 2019 I
Terry Collins being the afternoon
returned officer at the election do
hereby give notice there
the number of votes recorded for each
candidate at the civil action is as
follows brown Nicholas Allen brexit
party 2500 Ferrum to hit henna shodhan
the conservative and unionist party
24,000 and 67 Jolson Raymond Lawrence
Liberal Democrats 2133 Goodman Helen
Catherine the Labour Party 16,000 105
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
there were 130 ones there we are at gain
another gain for the Conservative Party
in Bishop Auckland not too high a
mountain for them to climb given that
they were only facing a 500 to vote
majority therefore Helen Goodman who
took it at the last election but look at
the size of that majority look what
they've turned it into nearly 8,000
majority in Bishop Auckland another
heavily leave voting seat taken over 50%
of the vote in Bishop Auckland labour
pushed down to 36% again laboured down
double digits 12.1 percent the
Conservatives up 6.8% and also the
brexit party up 5.6% worth talking
they're now going to stoke a dog their
Labour's Ruth Smith first of all your
exit poll is the exit poll is suggesting
that you're going to be in a bit of
trouble Ruth Smith I mean do you see it
that way seems it could be although I've
definitely lost well very frank of you
thank you very much indeed for
confirming that that makes it then a a
grim night personally and a really grim
night for the party
this is never mind the party this is an
appalling night for my constituents and
it's an appalling light for the country
and the Labour Party has huge huge
questions to answer by first of all
having this general election when they
were so ill prepared for it but then
having this option available to the
country having this platform having this
leadership and allowing this devastation
that hit all of our communities and this
is an appalling heartbreaking night for
the Labour Party but I'm much much more
worried about now what happens to my
constituents indeed well you say more or
less the Labour Party's let them down
where does the finger-point first of all
Jeremy Corbyn
has he got to go a Jeremy Corbyn tchard
announced that he is Lee he's resigning
as later at the Labor Party from his
count today I think he should have gone
over he should have gone and yo he
should have gone
many many many months ago I am I was the
parliamentary chair of the Jewish labor
movement we passed a vote of no
confidence in him in April
there is absolutely no justification for
why he's still there and his personal
actions have delivered this result for
my constituents and for Suede's of the
country overnight well mana saying the
guilty man well what about this issue of
dealing with anti-semitism in the labour
party do you see there was so much talk
about it but we never really seem to see
any evidence of solid disciplinary
action being taken yeah well I think
it's very clear that when someone says I
haven't got human blood and they're not
even suspended from the labour party
when someone says vile misogynistic
things about people like me and others
words I wouldn't use on sky TV and they
are not expelled from the labour party
suggest that we have a problem and I
don't care what Jeremy Corbyn and Jenny
fooled me have said about anti-semitism
in the locality and how they've dealt
with it they simply have not and in
terms of anti-semitism that was you know
the internal party processes how did
that play from your perspective in this
general election was it was it raised
with you as an example of one of the the
faults of the leadership jeremy corbyn's
actions on anti-semitism have made us
the nasty party we are the racist party
and when you've got a leader a prime
minister that has said such vile
Islamophobic comments and we're the
racist party because of the actions of
my leader the lack of actions of it and
who he's associated with and these
friends are then we have a real real
problem the Labour Party now these
detoxifies
we need to move on and we need to make
sure that this culture is destroyed
within the Labour Party that racism has
no place that there is no hierarchy of
racism and that everybody makes it clear
that Jews have a safe space in the
Labour Party because quite frankly they
don't at the moment you mean you've got
the recipe there do you see any prospect
of it actually happening given who's in
control of the party apparatus I'm sorry
Ruth Smith with hopefully we would be
able to continue that but they're
declaring its cities of London and
Westminster now this one of the hopeful
chipper of mana formerly of the Labour
Party now with Olympics and 49
McLaughlin Gillian Mary McLaughlin
commonly known as Jill McLaughlin
Christian People's Alliance 125 Nidal
Gordon Lawrence Labour Party 11,000 624
Polanski Zach Green Party 728 Oh Mona
chukka Harrison Liberal Democrats 13,000
and 96 okay well there we are
look at that 13,000 for chukerman and
the Lib Dems and the Labour Party taking
over 11,000 would easily have
outstripped Niki akin who've taken it
have held it for the Conservative Party
so much for tactical voting all these
websites and apps we were told about
though people were going to get their
act together and take these kind of
seats and all that very notes want to go
over to Chingford and talk to the former
leader of the Conservative Party in
Duncan Smith there you are mr. Duncan
Smith they returned there in Chingford
don't if you can eat me mr. Duncan Smith
hello
sky sky new sorry sir you may have heard
John Burke oh there Oh from
familiar voice to you on this issue yon
right on this issue of the of the
tactical voting and this remain alliance
or whatever it wanted to call itself
they came pretty close to getting rid of
you well I think it there was definitely
some tactical voting in this seat and I
think the biggest problem is that we
haven't settled brexit so now I hope and
believe that with Boris Johnson getting
what looks like an overall majority I
hope a good substantial one then we have
a chance now to bring this whole thing
to an end
get brexit done get that trade deal that
we talked about finish it all off the
only way I think will bring society
together again over this issue and stop
this being an issue at every election
and even in people's private life is to
do that to get brexit done and that's
what Boris Johnson is the only one that
made that promise otherwise if it have
been anybody else we've been meandering
along for another six months to a year
with no decisive results so getting that
majority was critical and I believe
Boris Johnson is a one nation prime
minister and I don't think he's going to
expend his time doing anything else he's
gonna do brexit he's gonna do well
strain it more police on the streets
sorry mr. Duncan Smith they're gonna try
and be snappy because a lot of results
is you know coming in but just on the
issue of brexit when you've been so
concerned about for so long particularly
under the previous leader I mean say
you've called it get brexit down we all
know it's only the withdrawal agreement
do you think then that it all can be
done and dusted that the trade
association and all that hangs off that
by the end of 2020
I think it's wholly feasible because a
lot of this work has already been scoped
by the civil service and the Foreign
Office behind the scenes the brexit
Department have already been scoping out
what the arrangements are and they've
been discussing those with the EU it's
not as though it's going to start from
scratch in January the reality is it is
feasible to do that they want a deal I
think this majority that we're going to
get now it looks like with the
Conservative Party does also do
something for that negotiation it tells
the European Union you're now dealing
with a government that can get things
through which means now settlement is
almost instantaneous it'll come back to
Parliament and we'll be able to get
these things okay
so the meeting so that relationship
changes between the two but I mean mr.
Duncan Smith he can get things through
I'm sorry gotta cut it off going to
Belfast North because Nigel Dodds they
at Westminster leader of the Democratic
Unionist Party standing there will he
hold on 35 to 1 1 3 5 4 newton-john chin
thean 23,000 and 78 one might say the
biggest scalp of the evening so far
Nigel dogs their leader at Westminster
of the Democratic Unionist Party lost
his seat to John four new Kundera
version fame the Lord Mayor Belfast John
Finnegan son Pat felucca net who was
killed in a terrorist shooting but he's
taken the seat 20 3078 you may notice
there very few standing there the SDLP
stood down a form of remain alliance
that was turned by shin Fane they taken
the seat from Nigel Dodd says gone in
Belfast North John Bercow well that is
the biggest scale for the night Nigel
Dodds is a long-serving member of Poland
he has a very high profile but with that
high profile has come controversy and if
you are a big figure you're a big target
and Nigel dance was a big target and
that's reflected not just in the
identity of his shin vein opponent but
in the fact that other candidates
withdrew in order to give shin pain the
best possible chance and what that
really is about is very very very strong
hostility I think to the DUP s position
on brexit Beth and just to pick up I
mean I was watching that because we
thought that Nigel Dodds might lose that
seat but we've talked a lot about
Scotland and the issue of brexit and how
that affects Scotland but of course of
Northern Ireland and how world Boris
Johnson's brexit deal affect Northern
Ireland and will in the long term that
also need to suggest move perhaps a
border poll in Northern Ireland as well
you know that is another con
to tional issue that comes out of this
election so one big constitutional
crisis resolved and other ones bubble up
Beth it's interesting isn't it because
one can't help but think that if forced
to choose between the Union and brexit
the DUP would go for the Union but for
the time being they have strongly
supported brexit and I think that they
are a great regret that let's just throw
in there the Conservatives have gained
Eastbourne from the Liberal Democrat so
it's not all bleak for them in the
southeast as well Beth continue it's
just going to ask you John do you think
in retrospect the DUP would have been
smart to have batteries of may in her
withdrawal agreement bill because they
didn't back her and it didn't go through
but as that ambition to be for the whole
of the UK to be treated the same I'm
going to cut you off there because we
are approaching the top of the hour it's
so just about to turn three o'clock
there for an appropriate a moment the
moment to remind you that you are
watching this brexit election special
coverage right here through the night on
Sky News as it turns three o'clock let
me take you through the headlines so far